[Musique]
bienvenue à sans filtre le podcast on
parle de ce qu'ont vécu nos invités date
si tu cherches quant à moi de dôme
plantes
cette semaine on a reçu bernard laval et
le nutritionniste urbain nous parler
d'un sujet qui touche 100 % de
population la nutrition tout le monde
mange trois fois par jour puis on a
parlé du nouveau guide alimentaire
canadien qui est pas encore sorti mais
qu'ont eu les premières premières fuites
sur des couilles worley puis qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui change justement dans
dans l'alimentation des recommandations
qui sont faites on a aussi touché deux
points de vue uniques la nutrition oui
la santé mais aussi l'impact
environnemental des aliments qu'on mange
de voir les aliments dans toutes leurs
leur aspect plutôt que seulement
l'aspect nutritionnel santé on ne te
parler d'autre chose
quand on a parlé de là je pense a fait
le tour pas mal dans toutes les facettes
de la nutrition en tout cas une
conversation qui va peut être pousser
certaines personnes à changer leurs
habitudes à améliorer certaines affaires
et puis il ya un discours quand même
super simple c'est la comprendre
efficace alors une très belle rencontre
bernard laval et puis si jamais suite à
cette discussion là vous voulez modifier
vos habitudes de nutrition puis vous
allez voir réduire la consommation vient
de la faire que bernard prendre le plus
et bien on est pour vous le livre
[Musique]
dégager mais ce blog qui est un livre de
nutrition végétal donc qui est
facilement des étapes faciles pour
modifier vos habitudes de vie donc
utiliser le code promo podcast 20 aux
liens dans la description de cette vidéo
là pour vous procurer le livre de
recettes vegan mais pas plate pour 20%
de rabais dans ce jeu les piles recettes
sont bonnes ce sont cinq
exact c'est simple même pour vous qui si
vous avez pas cuisiner c'est un livre
parfait pour vous sinon on a notre chan
pétri en sont le répète à chaque semaine
parce que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qu'on nous on a du plaisir à faire parce
qu'on crée du contenu exclusif pour les
membres petrone donc dernièrement a fait
un coup aux aînés ou est ce que les
un membre de notre mini communauté
pétulant non on poser des questions et
on a répondu sous forme de deux potes et
on va faire d'autres cancers donc allé
voir sur la chaîne pétrone pour vous
abonner pour avoir du conte exclusive
faut avoir les podcasts avance donc le
lien du pq on va être également dans la
description de cette vidéo si c'est
surtout pour dans le fond de ceux ci
pour nous encourager ces soirées mai
puis c'est qu'il soyez là on est déjà
extrêmement reconnaissants puis si vous
voulez vraiment faire l'étape de plus
pour nous montrer que vous êtes des
super fan ses consultations ce fait
puissent nos nouveaux abonnés à la
chaîne on sort du caucase pardon tous
les mardis puis on vous aime
on vous aime beaucoup laissez un
commentaire
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la
conversation qu'ont avec bernard pire
nous on essaie de lire les commentaires
on le sait répondre à tous les
commentaires puis sinon bonne écoute
bon pas de casque
[Musique]
bernard laval et merci d'être ici mais
merci pour l'invitation
oui comme tu disais avant qu'on commence
à tourner d'autres croyais que tu étais
en vacances encore non aujourd'hui c'est
officiellement pu me battre mais
intervenue plus tôt un petit peu à cause
de la nouvelle du guide alimentaire
canadien puis c'est sûr que l'on m'en
parler lorsque c'est intéressant quand
même les changements qui sont apportées
par le nouveau guide canadien en fait
qui va sortir éventuellement on ignore
qu'un mais dont on sait les grandes
lignes dans le fond - ouais pour eux
c'est comme la grosse nouvelle dans mon
milieu
comme j'étais comme un brin tchèque mes
amis sionistes en fin de semaine il faut
faire si besoin des filles la première
chose c'est comme une bonne année et
rien d'autre avancer parce que pour nous
c'est comme la grosse nouvelle c'est la
part des années que vous l'attendez
aussi le ladder la version comme
actuelle mais tant qu'on fait comme
s'ils n'étaient pas encore arrivés
laisse la version actuelle à 2007
l'examen longtemps si moi j'ai commencé
à étudier une triste on était déjà le
gué de la musique moi c'est le seul que
j'ai connu dans ma carrière etc oui ça
fait longtemps qu'il va piller tête
ainsi que des motifs il lui tond ton
livre pour le dernier lot travail
prévient qu'elle était moche à la fois
tu dis le dal prochain équipe qui parle
en 2015 je pense qu'on sera déjà qui est
il l'attend mais oui non mais c'est sûr
parce que de toute façon on savait qu
elle avoir une thune refondu qui était
attendu mais déjà en 2016 si je me
trompe peut-être mais en 2015
on savait qu'ils avaient quelque chose
qui s'en venait puis aux états unis et à
chaque cinq ans qui m'ont fait avoir
modifications nous on ne peut dans la
réglementation donc à chaque tant
d'années on doit faire la modification
nous unissent et chaque cinq ans et
comme en 2015 des états unis ont eu
leurs un nouveau guide je mettais pas un
peu là dessus pour voir qui le premier
parce que
en fait l'on prend et revenir médecine
l'environnement par le passé faisait pas
partie des recommandations et se dit le
guide c'est comme quoi manger pour être
en santé pour les humains point final
mais le moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
voit de façon plus globale fixe en plus
sur le terrain on est vraiment dans
cette mouvance lance moment puis mettons
tout impressionné les grandes lignes de
ces gars de là est-ce que tu étais
d'accord puisqu'ils et la hesse qui
était critique sais quoi mais tonton
opinion là dessus mais là celui qui met
tant la version 2007 passe encore la
version qui est officiel pour qu'on ait
eu des grosses critiques qui avaient
c'était grosso modo 1
comme je disais qu'on ne s'attaque qu'à
la santé humaine on compense pas plus
loin plus larges comme étant
l'environnement que je pense que c'est
super on s'est acquitté de 2007 a
maintenant et il ya eu une grosse
mouvance sociétaires par rapport à
l'environnement c'est surtout juste mais
on est de 2 3 dernières années n'ont
fait que de fermer les yeux sur ce way
exactement sauf que c'est un changement
qu'ils aient fait le tigre nettoient la
place maintenant du gouvernement ou est
ce que c'est c'est très comme rigide
comme structure un gouvernement fait
maintenant leur place que c'est comme
notre guide c'est comme ça qu'on a
toujours fait ça puis on doit continuer
de cette façon là pts les lobbys en irak
sont là pour dire si c'est que s'est
passé aux états unis
quant aux en 2015 quand ils ont voulu
intégrer l'environnement dans les
recommandations du guide en disant ben
maintenant on se rend compte qu'on est
en train de détruire la planète faut
qu'on y pense plus la façon dont on
mange ça peut avoir une influence donc
peut-être qu'ils sont recommande leur
donne des recommandations l'appui à la
population faut pas juste penser à la
santé d'aujourd'hui il faut penser à la
santé des prochaines générations que ça
ça passe en préservant l'environnement
en gros c'est cela les a fait quand ils
ont sorti une espèce de deux rapports
préliminaires avec avant qu'ils sortent
ils ont dit comme et voici qu'est ce
qu'on suggère bla bla bla y avait un
chapitre complet sur l'environnement sur
le fait qu'on aurait consommé moins de
viande parce que ça pourrait avoir un
impact positif sur la planète bla bla
bla tout ceux qui foulent de la bid et
la viande mais aussi ses disponibilités
les lettres qui ont été envoyées les
rencontres qui ont été faits soit 2
essais c'est relativement facile à
accéder parce que ça fait partie des
documents publics puis donc les six
autres clients beaucoup de la bi puis
quand le nouveau guide des sorties y
avait pas une seule fois le mot
environnement rempli je l'appréciais
absolument ils ont pas du tout
recommandé de diminuer la consommation
de viande en partie à cause des lobbys
puis l'argument qui était sorti ses
séductions vous dire c'est à dire non
non non un guide alimentaire c'est pour
la santé santé tous restés puis un
deuxième et en ligne sony êtes pas
capable de parler d'autre chose que de
nutrition fait qu'il reste hélas que
vous connaissez vous connaissez pas les
trucs d'environnement avec parlez-en
peuple changeait pas affecter un peu
pour discréditer finalement le messager
pour que le message passe pas par
rapport à mai c'est fou mais temps quand
tu quand tu considères que des lobbys
comme ce peut faire peuvent altérer
littéralement l'histoire des jeux durent
six admettons que le step et pris 10 ans
valls a fait une large différence sur
l'impact que c'est le halal jeter sur 10
ans la consommation de viron avait déjà
jusque là en ce moment on s'entend que
cc c'est en mouvance le telemos pause
puis la consommation de viande et et vue
très différents
différemment que vous le 10 ans par
exemple mais de savoir que un jeu de
lober modifier notre perception de soi
pendant longtemps cessé
c'est frustrant pour monsieur madame
tout le monde
puis pour moi aussi tout ceci si une
partie dans mon deuxième livre justement
d'avaler tout ce qu'on vous dit fait
l'historique un peu de ça 2 comment
certains lobbys ont réussi à modifier
des recommandations nutritionnelles ou
même des croyances qu'on a
puis un exemple que je donne parce que
au canada on ne peut de temps
d'historique que ce sa peau était comme
répertoriés mais aux états unis vraiment
plus depuis l'exemple que je donne 6 par
rapport à l'industrie du sucre
grosso modo dans les années genre 64 70
90 heures on a commencé à voir comme oy
plus de maladies du coeur on sait pas
trop d'où ça provient qu'est ce qui se
passe dans la blanc puis avec comme deux
écoles de pensée que s'affrontaient une
école de pensée qui disait c'est les
gras saturés qui sont moins mauvais qu
une école de pensée qui disent et le
sucre qui est le mauvais et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé c'est que l'industrie du
sucre comme elle avait peur de ce
message là de dire le succès pas gonfler
faut pas manger ils ont donné de
l'argent ils ont financé plein pépin
d'études sur les gras saturés
tous les chercheurs qui s'intéressent à
110 ans si on vous donne l'argent qu'on
vous donne de l'argent pour faire la pub
pour faire mais regardez de l'autre côté
et factuel on va juste regarder du côté
des gras saturés en cas de repos du côté
du suc et c'est ce qui s'est passé
exactement à son gouvernement talent
sont devenus attention au gras saturés
attention grâce et le gros méchant dans
notre alimentation c'est le gras
attention pas son intention on ne peut
pas parler de sucre mais c'est parce
qu'il ya eu des lobbys en arrière qui
ont donné un porte-voix à ses chercheurs
pour qu'on parle juste des grâces a du
rythme qu'on en oublie cela coûtait
piste et pas nécessairement en plus de
commandes il explique ce c'est pas de
cacher les études par rapport au succès
juste de financer les études sur le côté
elle s'entend très bien que les
résultats de ces études la halle à être
négative
c'est avec des études qui était
catégorique sur le le gras saturés
exactement parce que le chercheur mais
tant qu'un des chercheurs qui finançait
c'est un saut qui puisse se charger le
lui ça
sa théorie c'est baisser les graisses
saturées sais je sais qu'ils regardaient
mais qu'ils ont pas c'est pas des
fausses d'études qui sont au rsa mais
ils ont donné de l'argent à celui qui
faisait des études qui allaient dans le
sens qu'ils voulaient maintenant est-ce
que c'est pas à cause des labbes il se
peut aussi que pas la recommandation que
pour le pourcentage besoins
nutritionnels par jour ces métaux et des
mines cette voie mettons notre jus
d'orange c'est 100% wever mais le suc il
n'y a pas ce pourcentage le parce que
d'intérêts tout le temps facilement un
choix ouais j'ai eu beaucoup ça c'est
vraiment un gros dossier pige marche pas
que je vais rentrer l'armée dans ce sens
tout comme on n'en avait pas on serait
pas trop comme que sais tu ce secret a
ajouté cet suspense devient tendue par
des secrets les besoins dans les années
qui ont un nouveau thème qui est arrivé
grosso modo à des heures à les liquides
les soutenir grosso modo ces déçus qui
sont demandés si rodez liquide chez
terra donc ça comprend les sucres
ajoutés ferme et ont su se faire un café
mais ton petit mais du sucre de danse
est un sucre les bruce ivins sucre
ajouté mais ça peut être ici le sucre
dans les jus de fruits mais tonton actes
et dakhla les gens se mélangent et parce
que c'est naturel c'est bon mais l'autre
sucre glace y avait comme un gros flou
là bas puis on n'avait pas vraiment
d'études qui monterait à qui sait quel
type de sucre aimant qui est néfaste
pour la santé peut-être puis quand on
regarde les étiquettes c'est juste sucre
qui est écrit on n'y a pas de
distinction entre les différents types
de sucre
donc c'est difficile arrête même au
canada on avait peuple
j'avoue que je le sais plus par caen
mais je suis même pas sûr qu'on a une
recommandation même officine en ce
moment c'est vraiment les sucres libres
en tant que tel combien on devrait
consommer quand on regarde les
recommandations de plaine pays c'est le
gros fouillis fondation se ressemblent
pas parce qu'on parle de type de sucre
différents mais en gros en ce moment là
moi la recommandation sur laquelle je me
bats c'est celle de loi mais selon
l'organisation mondiale de la santé us y
recommande c'est moins que 50 g de
sucres libres par joe hahn qui se sait à
peu près l'équivalent de 13 cuillérées à
thé de sucre la mettons que messi sauf
que justement c'est une compo juste de
ce que tu étais où le sirop d'érable
majorité du sucre d'où il provient dans
notre alimentation c'est les boissons
sucrées fixer les boissons gazeuses
même si on boit moins une boisson
gazeuse maintenant mais c'est est
remplacé par les eaux vitaminées les
cafés aromatisés
les boissons énergisantes les boissons
pour sportifs lillers mathy depuis la
parole c'est comme ceux qui sont devenus
la principale source de sucre entre
alimentation qui même sans dire de
chiffres parce que moi dans la vie je ne
peux parler de sa manche c'est trop
complexe pour les gens enfin je dirais
comme consommer le moins possible et 50
grammes
c'est comme la recommandation officielle
mais ça ne colle à présenter beaucoup de
gars comme une canette de coca c'est
quelque chose dont 35 g accueillir une
canette et demi il tape après bosty tata
recommandations fake c'est vraiment pas
beaucoup si ça aussi c'est que les gens
ont l'impression des fois que c'est
comme extrêmes comme recommandations qui
sont comme l homme michael jamais être
capable de faire simple c'est comme mais
c'est vrai que si tu bois des boissons
scris tu vois là mais c'est que on est
tellement habitué à ces aliments le les
aliments transformés
on est rendu tellement habitué les
avants dans notre alimentation que ça
devient bizarre et difficiles depuis les
consommer le problème c'est pas sympa
que la recommandation est trop stricte
le problème c'est que notre alimentation
est devenu trop loin de caisse qui est
vraiment bon pour nous c'est vraiment ce
fait que oui ça à sa demande
faut qu'on tire les gens vraiment dans
un un autre extrait mais comme à l'autre
bout du spectre
parce que pour corriger quelque chose
souvent on fonctionne par l'exagération
le temps pour corriger des ddd
est facile de la vie moche et mettons
pour parler de expérience précise mais
ton chez en natation par exemple c'est
pour que le mouvement faut que tu fasses
l'exagération ti pour ramener ces au
centre et donc des complètement à droite
obtenant un but complètement à gauche
c'est exact en ce qui a trait au sud moi
j'ai des problèmes de consommation de
bonbons qui j'ai des noms mais pauvres
et des prix à la consommation du gym
puis qui la façon que je réussis les
fois que j'ai réussi à comment sortir
dans un but c'est juste d'arrêter
complètement genre de 0,6 chez une fois
tendance
je garde les lieux si on désire le camp
j'arrêtais mettons peu après un mois je
ressens plus le besoin
c'est comme le lien sacs de jute en eau
du frij urgent et danger des vies puis
je le garde là parce que mon mois de
janvier je le fais sans que j'y pense
qu'à chaque fois que je passe devant ça
me rappelle le gil good le plan to
flagelle le 10 mai le gie le goût de
prendre sauf que chez mes tongs dans
trois semaines
j'aurais pu me le prendre sur le fait
mais tu vois moi ma philosophie par
rapport à ses pas ça fait similaires
souvent ce que je vais recommander aux
gens c'est plutôt que justement d'aller
dans l'extrême de couper à 100% vaut
mieux aller vers le milieu avec ce genre
de choses noté si justement t'habitues
manger des jeux bat chaque jour on va
dire tant pis maintenant tu manges un
sac de jeu par jour on veut dire mais
jour l'an mais tu arrêtes ça se peut
très bien que tu sois capable de te fait
pendant une semaine deux semaines trois
semaines un mois deux mois trois mois et
qu'après traumatise pas georges plus
capable le jouet ce que tu commences à
manger parce que comme un être humain tu
peux pas te restreint toute ta vie
l'alimentation c'était mondiale aux
émotions qui on a des maisons dix ans
est un être humain fait c'était moyenne
aux émotions qu'on peut pas se
restreindre toute notre vie fait qu'on
finit toujours par retomber dans le sac
de jujubes où la mode de biscuits ou
prépa avec plutôt que d'aller dans cette
extrême le mans je recommande plutôt de
ce qui prend un stack de jeu par jour
commençons par un sac de jeu bat chaque
deux jours un demi sac parle par jour
d'après ce pétrin corps de cinq par jour
puis après ça va peut-être trop jeu par
jour
ça va avoir vraiment vraiment vraiment
diminué peut-être que tu es content avec
s'appuie sur pas sentir la restriction
je donne un exemple - personnel c'est
avec la viande par exemple comme moi
j'ai une famille ou à ski depuis la
plupart des gens je pense ont été élevés
dans des familles où est ce qu'on mange
de la viande tous les jours c'est normal
c'est ça notre société et était basé
beaucoup là dessus c'est en train de
changer
mais quand j'ai commencé à m'intéresser
plus justement l'environnement petit
j'ai voulu diminuer ma consommation de
viande mais je les fais tellement de
façon graduelle que je ne suis jamais
rendu compte finalement ça a juste pris
un moment donné je fais comme elle c'est
vrai ça fait genre un an que j'ai pu
acheter de viande hachée nous nous
donnons même mais je m'en étais juste
jamais rendu compte parce que je me suis
je me suis jamais mis même la boîte
comme moi je suis végétarien est arrivé
comme pas exactement c'est comme j'ai
même pas mis cette restriction d'eau
dans ma tête pour un pape a raison donc
c'est comme vraiment facile puis je
ressens pas le besoin d'arriver trop
graduellement avec bref peu importe
habitude moi je recommande plus de
livres a rejoint cette dune sont le
graduel pour qu'on sente pas la
restriction c'est vraiment je m'associe
jallet mais admettons que ces dames
dans mon cas si j'ai l'impression gic
pratiquement une dépendance et on dirait
que ça crée sur mon système
ce genre de structure je pense que ça
crée carrément dépendance ben en fait
c'est sûr ça crée du plaisir point final
tu aimes ça hors du plaisir et peu
importe c'est quoi le jeu très peu trop
sur le thème dépendance le pich les
études à ce sens le sont assez
contradictoires fait que j'irais pas
jusqu'a mais que je peux dire c'est que
quand tu te restreint qui suit pas le
droit de manger ça mais on sait tous que
si tu dis j'ai pas vraiment j'ai surtout
pouvoir le manger des portes phares
telles choses vouloir leur façade vie
mais plus attrayant fake mais plus là
dedans je te dirai que je sais pas si
c'est de la bullshit où c'est vrai mais
nous sommes j'avais fait penser qu'il ya
les fêtes à sa guise ou rippy c'est
comme les souris devenez plus accros ce
cas la cocaïne
deux ans et plus on sait qu'à la caisse
[Musique]
mais je pense ou city puisque
logiquement témoin mettons moi mon avis
et c'est plus mettons les poutines que
les juges double mais ton métier c'est
vraiment qu'un que je vois dans genre
skipper repop genre vraiment trop faim
depuis le palais il faut que fallait
chercher a dit mcdowell à 20 puis aussi
c'est
plus tu marches de bonnes affaires -
t'as faim pour manger leurs peuples puis
plus tu bois de l'eau - togo de bangkok
fac-ci study qui mangent plus de fruits
et légumes qui boit plus d'eau tepa en
restriction était en train de manger les
bons aliments mais qu'il met en même
temps la envie d'aller manger mauvais
aliments et comme couper le parce que
t'es pas ultra fin août à pau focus sur
le positif plutôt que coupet négatif de
résumer mon bac 5
mais si ça comme vous réagi comme rien
parce que bon c'est pas cassé c'est
exactement ça pour rester comme je
voyais comme soumis non mais c'est ça
c'est que c'est nos messages les
messages qui fonctionne en nutrition le
sont vraiment plate qui on les répète
depuis toujours de boire majorité de
l'eau de manger plus de fruits de
légumes de cuisiner davantage
ainsi des messages qu'on répète depuis
toujours sont vraiment plate les gens
sont tannés d'aider les entends mais la
réalité c'est que c'est juste qu'ils
fonctionnent comme toutes les recettes
miracles dont on entend parler ça ne
fonctionne pas jamais mais c'est bien
plus séduisant de 10 est plus forte
qu'est ce que tu veux tout le temps mais
si pendant une semaine tu reste rien à
faire
x y z chose doit être correcte si mais
plus le fun mais la réalité c'est que ça
marche pas ce qui marche i link route
c'est exact exactement
mais c'est ça c'est concept durable
c'est que même si tu te resterait
pendant trois mois dans ta vie ou même
pendant un an le twin d'y être ou est-ce
que peu importe écrivez mais que messi
c'est juste un homme en toute ta vie
syrien nom de ta vie les pouvoirs de
l'alimentation n'est pas sur le court
terme généralement c'est sur le long
terme seulement avec ses habitudes sur
toute ta vie mais il reste qu'ils vont
avoir les pactes posture hd fait pendant
un mois ou même un an
c'est pas suffisant souvent pour que
dans quarante ans
ah oui quand j'avais 3 ans j'avais 10
ans quand j'ai pas mangé dessus pendant
un an des jeux ça changera rien sur
comme quand on aura 80 ans séparément
que ça va changer
mais si tu te déshabille toute ta vie
que tu vas ont retenu le ton
avec c'est vraiment un concept sauf que
ce soit durable pour que ça fonctionne
c'est ce qu'on oublie souvent de ville
c'est parce que le jour tous les
habitudes qui t'avait aventure vous
retournez tôt pour obama centrique table
avant lundi
totor wii qui nous habite se change pas
si facilement que ce non plus jamais
comme se faire quelque chose pendant
deux semaines comme ton habitude de 10
par jour en mai sa fonderie mais oui ça
prend vraiment du temps pour l'échangé
puis encore une fois moi je suis
vraiment dans le com graduelle pour que
ça fonctionne fixe à sa création le long
terme fougueusement que tu te rendes
peau qu'on lui pour que tu sois capable
que ça que ça fonctionne parce que dès
la seconde où soixante et une
restriction étudie j'aimerais commencer
manger de la crème glacée en ce moment
mais il me reste encore deux jours le
pied après j'avais le droit d'en manger
par genre fini tu en auras ma diète ou à
laver ou c'est mon type d où peu importe
la façon dont il réfléchit pas marche
pas tu es une restriction dans ta tête
dont tu seras pas capable de lire des
toute ta vie les gens qu'il ya des
restrictions toute leur vie ça se
rapproche des troubles alimentaires
il est capable de te reste rapide est
triste et de la façon dont tu manges tu
as ta vie mais ça ressemble à des
troubles alimentaires
mais encore une fois quelqu'un
maintenant qu'ils mangeraient pas de
sucre maintenant qu'on imagine c'est
quelqu'un qui disait en mange mange plus
de sucre pis il ne sent pas la
restriction qui est heureux comme ça
c'est pas un problème vraiment le style
mais une fois que l'habitude dé changer
c'est facile vous voulez photo
d'habitude et l'autre que c'est cet avis
soit en mode de vie puis sautez action
tout à chaque jour est facile si c'est
vraiment ça mais moi maintenant je vais
regarder l'exemple parce que je trouve
que c'est un bon exemple pour illustrer
des concepts moi qui admettons je mange
le sac double ça me rend pas heureux
c'est bon mais
ce serait même principe que ces mêmes
arguments que j'avais par exemple pour
eux ou que j'ai pour le monde qui me
disent oui mais j'aime ça mais dans mon
style
les mots je me dis mon cinq minutes de
plaisir gustatif
il me rend pas heureux après le thé
personne non plus je trouve pas que
c'est et je trouve pas que c'est dû
du banc tu es en dix ans le très court
terme c'est pas non plus tu sais ça
reste ça reste j'ai l'impression un
problème a adressé même si c'est même si
effectivement ce pas par la restriction
mais ça me rend pas plus heureux qui
comme le monde qui boivent du coq pas
parce que c'est leur habitude de bord du
coq le jeu ça les rend pas heureux
nécessairement c'est juste c'est leur
vie de faire c'est moi comment tu fais
pour changer cette habitude le camp
quand c'est juste soit on habitue depuis
là dessus mais c'est pour ça que ça
prend la volonté de le dire exactement
être capable de changer les habitudes
quelqu'un qui ne veut pas dire
impossible
quelque chose que souvent je dis aux
gens comme c'étaient des gens qui vous
est venu parler à mon frère le comme il
fait telle chose de vraiment changer
jusqu'au nom est comme ça c'est ça aussi
le poche angers ça sert à rien de le
décider de le convaincre de quoi que ce
soit il parle de la viande qui
diviserait c'est un super bon exemple ou
city c'est comme ça marche pas si tu dis
à quelqu'un comme et et essaie de
convaincre de pas manger de viande ou au
contraire des signes convainquant
végétarien de manger de la viande
si tu veux pas faire cette habitude le
tout nouveau mode la fin point final
les personnes qui veut récente qu'on
m'explique ça prend la volonté après la
pression tu peux aller chercher des
outils prêts capable de le faire par
exemple une soliste c'est ça notre job
c'est de nous donner des outils aux gens
ce comme un regard extérieur parce qu'on
dit la personne du bain voici ce que je
mange la vie puis comme nous à court de
notre formation on est capable devant un
peu les angles morts de ces personnes
note c'est comme ça mais dimanche c'est
comme y est une raison particulière
plombs ça creuse un petit peu si c'est
déjà avoir des psychologues simple la
même chose de thé un petit oiseau bleu
mort de ta pensée sont mais c'est un peu
la même chose c'est des engagements de
ton alimentation qui les angles morts de
pourquoi tu manges chip de questionner
sur ce parce que des fois c'est serge
baudy quo parce que ma mère j'ai savez
un coach à qui mais c'est tout seul que
bah je sais pas puisque wacom du coq
situent les bulles ou situe le secret du
coq c'est que le goût la mémoire de
comics en alabama sais quoi qui tant pis
si abc le petit saint joachim et
de logrian être précis ça va des fois
comment fait que c'est vraiment étonné
de voir comme de questionner les
habitudes alimentaires mais ça prend
d'abord la volonté c'est ce que si tu le
peux mais personne ne fait pas changé
après la volonté pis je pense que même
avant la volonté s'apprend m les
informations c'est tout le monde sait
mettons que le coq c'est pas bon c'est
le je pense qu'en 2019 maintenant je
pense que tout le monde le sait mais
mais encore du bon sens après de volonté
mais quelqu'un qui boit du jus d'orange
mais qui pense que c'est vraiment bon
pour lui qui sait pas mais ton qui est
en dessous d'un jus d'orange que dans le
côté tout revient à cette fameuse
polémique mais le problème est là c'est
qu'il le sait des gens qui pensent qu'on
les joue des choix santé
ce problème de volonté s'ils ont la
volonté faire la bonne chose mais sont
mal informées anonymes en quête pour les
bonnes c'est quelque chose qui compte
c'est que moi je me bats beaucoup plus
c'est vraiment plus là dessus
moi je m'en fous justement une boisson
gazeuse les gens parlent peut vraiment
ma vie parce que j'ai pas besoin de rap
à une nouvelle personne ne dira que
boire des boissons gazeuses comme tout
le monde le dit on s'en fout là où j'ai
des problèmes c'est quand on fait croire
aux gens que tel aliment
on a l'habitude est bonne pour eux mais
xi pauvre et c'est ce que j'appelle la
bullshit du personnel affecté c'est
vraiment pour moi c'est ce qui est plus
problématique c'est vraiment quand on
essaie de faire croire aux gens quelque
chose qui serait bon pour eux le jus
d'orange c'est un bon exemple si quand
on a commencé à parler du jus d'orange
nous devons consommer moins pour ceux
les gentils comme koodo un peu d'autres
chats à fouetter que de parler du jus
d'orange comme ça me dire des choses
perdant à vis de nos alimentations puis
comme oui vous avez vraiment raison et
des choses vraiment pire dans
l'alimentation
mais le problème c'est qu'en ce moment
on dit aux gens buvaient du jus d'orange
fait vraiment bon pour vous c'est dans
notre guide alimentaire canadien le
devoir du jus d'orange c'est comme
manger un fruit
c'est important pour moi de défaire ce
mec là parce que bella censés évaluer
puis les gens se font faire croire des
choses qui sont pauvres et ne peut pas
de donner de la volonté aux gens mais tu
peux donner aux gens qui ont la volonté
les bonnes performances seulement
oui c'est vraiment le oui je pense que
c'est l'homme qu'il à mon travail c'est
ça mon travail si je donne l'information
qui après les gens font qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent avec une épice pas là pour dire
festif et sosh comme voici les faits
après se tuer un adulte celui capable de
choisir pour toi même parce que
l'exemple ce côté humain ou la cigarette
moi je donne toujours cet exemple
l'auteur
tout le monde sait que le monde qui on
en a fait le des campagnes de
sensibilisation qui ont émis des taxes
qui ont tout bleu dit ça a marché on a
beaucoup beaucoup diminué les bons mais
est encore des fumeurs piano beaucoup
quand même
donc clairement il ya quelque chose
d'autre c'est clairement c'est comme la
lie connaissance ce n'est pas suffisant
pour arrêter puis mettons
je n'ai pas encore lu ton plus récent
livre j'ai l'intention de lire
prochainement
mais mettons le tout les fausses
croyances ou les fausses les choses qui
reviennent le plus souvent que les gens
pensent qu'ils sont vrais que sont bons
pour eux qu'ils sont qui sont peu s'il
est calé auxquels est confronté le plus
souvent de façon plus globale se dresser
un des maîtres que j'entends souvent
c'est le croire qu'un aliment faut
absolument couper un aliment de ce2 son
assiette pour être en santé ou au
contraire qu'il faut absolument
consommer un aliment pour être en santé
les gens pis ça change la au fil des ans
puis moi ça fait juste comme 5 6 ans
qu'elle soupçonnait depuis malgré tout
j'ai déjà l'impression d'avoir vu là oui
ça change toujours d'aliments compass
duquesnoy hockey ou arriveront sous peu
importe
qu'est ce que c'est on va toujours pas
c'est un aliment à l'autre où justement
les halles est un poison on en voit
absolument conserver un autre poison qui
peu importe ce qu'on parle mais c'est
fou enfin il y au coeur si l'on parle
d'un animal c'est pas aucun aliment que
si tu en manges de temps en temps
quelqu'un être un poison même boisson
gazeuse
quand on sait que c'est pas bon c'est
pas vrai de dire que si tu bois un coq
un nom donné par semaine exactement
surtout si le reste ton alimentation
c'est quand des aliments frais peut
transformer tout ça on s'en fout de ton
cox est tellement pas grave qui au
contraire de penser qu'il faut
absolument manger tel fruit ou tel
légume ou tel aliment pour être en santé
c'est toujours comme des sauvages qu'on
nous dit tu vas dans la jeune coeur à
des tribus entières comme manger depuis
toujours passé quand faut absolument que
ce manchot c'est n'importe quoi comme
les skis d'importance la diversité
alimentaire c'est pour les aliments en
tant que tel
moi ça m'a crié un vertige en avait
suivi on a suivi une clinique la
clinique renversant si c'est quoi non je
crois que oui oui elle a donné une
clinique de 12 semaines pour les gens
qui veulent transférer à une
alimentation végétale puis bien faire
seul
il le dernier corps portait sur quand
même comme c'est amener tout
tout les petits pourcentage
supplémentaire que tu peux aller
chercher pour avoir une alimentation
optimale à key west île s était déjà
forte émane a réagi à ce site et si vous
faites tout sur vous allez juste faire
c'est dans votre vie parce que c'est
trop d'enfants c'était comme le studieux
maximise et on aille au cul l'aco qu'en
tant que la coupe puis que thales 20 mai
lieu de couper avant de la même dans des
affaires où médecins et moi j'étais là
quelqu'un qui veut vivre cette
alimentation optimale
ça devient la chose qu'il faut que tu
fasses parce que tout peut plus le temps
de faire rien d'autre
elle prépare et on va mieux deux
d'avancé sa demande et seulement 20
minutes de plus et ce prix mais c'est sa
demande d'un mieux de plus puis pitt
c'est moi et moi ça m'écrire une espèce
de vertige et déjà qu'ils savaient fait
aussi prendre un step back de me dire
c'est pas nécessaire d'aller d'aller
chercher toutes sortes 100% d'accord on
est dans une société de performance
parce que peu importe qu'elles se faire
de notre vie on parle on essayait comme
le meilleur puis de faire le mieux
possible puis les messages qui sont
envoyées par les médias partout monde si
je m'en foutiste d'être comme mais mieux
puis commenta milieu rip comment faire
mieux ce ppi la sphère l'alimentation
est touchée aussi par ce phénomène qui
clairement ceci dit si par exemple la
robe et comme petit couple a good day
one ever be moi ce que je voyais souvent
ce thème et on les passe que dans
l'élite au maquis une molécule qu'on
appelle le lycopène un antioxydant plomb
s'est rendu compte que si tu ne manges
et transforme et à tomates avec la
manger mettons sous forme de sauce
tomate ou à la rue c'est encore mieux
que de la manger fragile mais ce que moi
que tu avais plus de lycopène si tu
faisais quand on fait chauffer la tomate
sera libéré où elle avait fait avec le
chauffer votre tomates pour avoir plus
de cette molécule le peuple comme oh mon
dieu c'est vraiment compliqué qui
réalistement ce que ça va avoir un
impact positif sur la vie des gens je
suis posture pis le très bien dit si un
moment donné l'alimentation devient la
seule chose que tu es dans ta vie c'est
un problème si la wii c'est un très gros
problème donc
il faut pas que ça empiète sur les
autres sphères de notre vie non plus
même si c'est quelque chose qui nous
intéresse plus quelque chose quand on
veut bien faire ou country fun à faire
ça doit pas être la seule chose qu'on a
dans notre vie d'alimentation qui s'est
rendu qu'il faut que tu passes comme
plusieurs heures par jour à cuisiner à
gré à tous de faire ça peut être grave
et on aille piles et il a laissé 20
minutes comtois
j'espère que tu es optimiser toutes les
autos la régler avant face au musée la
clinique dur est justement d'où ce même
jeu c'est juste le dernier cours le tir
parce que tout le reste c'est juste voir
comment tout maximiser les autres
grosses dans ce contexte ça commence par
couper les produits d'origine animale et
toupie mais ça c'était vraiment iront
toutes ces affaires là justement les
tomates on l'a vu aussi dans cette danse
et secours le passé comme si tu veux
vraiment une fois tout le reste est fait
et les 11 dernières semaines si tu veux
amener sur encore un autre niveau ceci
c'est à faire le métier assure que
beaucoup de monde qui bon ce métier mais
tant que tu arrêtes en deuxième semaine
le petit fait possible d'aller chercher
le point que pour ça je sais pas si je
vais vous donner le punch de mon dernier
livre parce que comme mon lit se termine
avec 5 trucs grosso modo comme top 250
pages mais contrôlé très sérieusement
[Rires]
mais non à ma blonde tu es à moi et nous
avons des photos nos récifs des genres
sont à l'image arrêt j'ai pris une photo
je voulais faire votre piscine fait
cadeau au havre où j'ai pris une photo
je me souviens avoir lu des trucs qu est
ce que tu es des chanteurs qui dit que
maintenant les fans venaient alors
concert pire at il dit
c'est le nouveau piratage d'élite cette
saga décroche un peu
[Rires]
bref ça se termine en 5 trucs vraiment
facile puis pour moi ces cinq trucs
leçon en masse suffisant pour être en
meilleure santé que la majorité des gens
dans les pays industralisés
grosso modo c'est de manger le moins
transformés pacifique manger des
aliments frais manger le plus de
végétaux possible fait que la majorité
de ce qu'on mange des fruits des légumes
des légumineuses décrit un céréalier
anti des noix tutorat de s'écouter et
d'écouter sa fin donc comme canto fin
dimanche contre pau fin tu manges pas
original de bord de l'eau en très grand
majorité puis finalement de de faire une
place au plaisir dans l'alimentation
parce que on parle souvent de la santé
quand on parle d'une crise on prépare
ton par la santé physique très souvent
on oublie la santé mentale comme si
c'étaient deux choses séparées ou même
que la santé mentale ça existe comme que
ce point important mais on a senti comme
un être humain et donc santé mentale
sont et physx avant-centre qui donc si
le plaisir n'est plus là mais ça marche
pas peu importe pourquoi que le plaisait
plus ça marche le peuple sera pas car de
garder ses habitudes sur toute ta vie
noté ça se résume en cinq trucs
l'opinion ou donc bref de manger moins
300 me plonge des végétaux tout le monde
le sait tout le monde le sait que c'est
ce qu'on doit faire
mais c'est ce qui fonctionne c'est
lorsqu'on de puces de science c'est là
où est ce que on sait que ça fonctionne
sur le long terme mais si plate les gens
ils veulent comme la nouveauté qui
cherchent des travaux optimiser conseil
cuite est à matt va voir 92% plus de
lycopène ou salaires nice comme big
apple
c'est vraiment bon en plus c'est bon
pour la prostate avec le ou les cures
manger manger autrement ce n'est pas ok
mais tu dis ok mais ça me gave à la
saint valentin
typiquement il va toujours avoir des
espèces d'articles de même d'une triste
comme manger des huîtres parce que ça le
5 c'est bon pour la fin de même le tout
le temps ou comme un aphrodisiaque
oui c'est manger vos tomates par ses
bons prostate
c'est n'importe quoi c'est tellement
n'importe quoi on passe de comme un
nutriment qui ont un effet particulier
sur la santé que l'on extrapole 110 ans
comme le si tu manges ça ça compte et ça
donc ça va voir ça donc le soir une
belle soirée qu aucun rapport loki
c'est comme ça qu'on parle de nutrition
maintenant tu vas te ridiculiser tout
souriant d'un sommet la réalité c'est
que plein de gens qui y vivent des
articles sérieux c'est exactement ce
qu'ils disent est ce vraiment stupide
notre souffrance et du cours n'importe
quoi je pense tu connais jean philippe
sueur oui bien sûr lui et avait une
bonne phrase puis l'huile disant pas la
blague parce qu'il parlait des maladies
coronariennes que l'alimentation
végétale pouvait aider puis à la phrase
problème de quéquette change ton
assiette c'est tout et souvent non mais
c'est vrai le blizzard et ça fonctionne
pour vrai c'est que c'est bon pour que
c'est bon pour la santé c'est quoi la
dilatation des vaisseaux adjoint
pourrait rebondir là dessus tout dit que
ça fait ça fait combien de temps que tu
t'es végétarien c'est non mais ce
qu'elle fit pas qu'à moi je me qualifie
peu comme c'est déjà la consommation
safetic hommes depuis peut-être 2014
quand j'ai commencé à travailler sur mon
livre plus que j'ai commencé à diminuer
la consommation de viande pour des
raisons environnementales
majoritairement environnement c'est que
ce qui me motive parce qu'elle est
vraiment de plus en plus nutritionniste
qui qui sont végétariens végétaliens
puis
j'imagine qu'ils seront par pas d'un
serment par souci environnemental toute
la gamme c'est souvent un pain de la
question mérite sunice t'intéresses à la
santé j'ai l'impression que corrigez moi
si je me trompe que c'est pas
nécessairement à moins que les cullen
l'éthique animale vienne le chercher
mais j'ai l'impression que c'est plus
par comme tu disais sans enlever la
viande c'est d'augmenter tout la
consommation de viande de végétaux qui
fait que la viande éventuellement prend
place place absolument
mais tu vois c'est pour des questions
généralement une motivation c'est une
question de santé qu'elles sont environ
mentale puis huit questions d'éthique
animal certainement pour moi ce qui me
ce qui me fait mon vrai déclic le pij
rapace dans mon premier livre les gens
partent toujours mes conférences et un
livre des listes d eau ni celle qui
délivre sur l'éthique animale puis c'est
son premier livre je mange avec ma tête
moi c'est ce qui me colle c'est comme
quand on pense à vous qui comme c'était
seul c'est comme j'ai pris son livre
j'ai vu en une nuit
pis j'ai capoté parce que donc on
parlait de gaspillage alimentaire de
pollution de l'impact de la
transformation la production le
transport des aliments sur la santé des
travailleurs sur la planète mais aussi
sur le bien-être des animaux qui j'étais
en train de faire ma maîtrise en ce
moment à ce moment là qu'ils jetaient
com comment ça se fait que j'aie jamais
entendu parler ces sujets là dans mes
cours je en train de terminer ma
maîtrise en nutrition
moi j'ai jamais ça jamais parlé des
conséquences des recommandations que je
donnerais aux gens un répit pour moi
c'était comme un déclic c'est là que
j'ai commencé à m'y intéresser davantage
père me rends compte que et non je peux
parler une dénutrition qui restait sur
mon petit focus de jeu nutriments santé
humaine ont l'alimentation c'est
tellement plus large avec vous qu'on le
voit dans son ensemble qui a des
conséquences
donc c'est des questions de valeurs mais
les conséquences sont plus guère plus
grande que que juste la santé humaine
qui vous aimez ici c'est vraiment plus
macro que micro noces que leur histoire
ce qui m'intéresse c'est la santé comme
tu dit tantôt la santé ton enfant c'est
important depuis ton enfin le repas de
santé si on prend pas des enjeux plus
importants 1 1 conques
c'est absolument clair nous avons très
souvent les problématiques
environnementales d'aujourd'hui
revient des problématiques de santé
publique dans les années à ce effet cui
moi je pense que c'est essentiel que des
professions de la santé s'intéresse en
environnement parce que ça va toucher la
santé du futur nos phobies des exemples
que je peux donner un exemple qui
mouille en tête c'est on a une
problématique au québec puis ailleurs
dans le monde des algues bleues d'entrer
là qu'ils voient ce qui va avoir une
prolifération d'algues c'est causé par
des des engrais on utilise en
agriculture en font des engrais de
synthèse qui donc ce qui est
problématique environnementale parce que
donc ça nuit à la biodiversité quand les
lacs de vienne comme pris avec ce
problème la nouvelle a dû diverses
problématiques environnementales
mais c'est passé c'est qu'il y avait des
communautés qui s'abreuvaient de l'eau
de ces lacs le pipi qui ne pouvaient
plus boire de l'eau de cela parce qu'ils
étaient contaminés par des hommes puis
les usines d'épuration et t'es pas cap
en décidant de retirer tout cas tout
qu'est-ce qu'ils étaient deux dans l'eau
qui je me suis une couple d'années
j'avais lu un article dans la presse je
sais plus quoi
ou est ce que c'est une municipalité
justement qui avaient des premiers matic
date bleus dans ces lacs qui il avait
fait un avis à la population dix ans pas
grave on vous pouvez boire l'eau de
robinet quand même s'il y aura pas de
problème mais donner le pas de bébé
[Rires]
faites comme ça tu donc la conséquence
environnementale la problématique
environnementale
une problématique de santé publique
directement c'est comme même maintenant
mais dans les prochaines années c'est la
même chose
l'écrasement de la biodiversité ça va
être une grosse problématique pour nous
les différentes et les cultures sont
cultive pas beaucoup d'aliments en ville
comme on mange très très peu diversifiée
en réalité et donc s'ils ont des
cultures qui deviennent sont affectés
par les changements climatiques par
exemple sens on s'attend ce que dans à
chaque la leffe house comme la branche
des nations unies qui s'intéressent à
l'agriculture et à l'alimentation
ils s'attendent à ce que chaque décennie
on va perdre à peu près 2% de production
alimentaire à cause des changements
climatiques avec même en comptant qu'on
va augmenter là qu'on veut avoir des
technologies non c'est sûr qu'au
ordinaire technologie tout ça on va
avoir deux pour cent de moins de
production alimentaire qui ça peut
paraître peu 2% soit augmentée ça fait
qu'on a un problème notamment en 2050 on
va avoir plus que deux milliards de plus
de bouches à nourrir en ce moment on est
incapable de nourrir tout le monde puis
on va n'y a pas de produire de moins en
moins on s'en va vers un mur carrément
donc si si vraiment problématique donc
les problématiques d'aujourd'hui ce
environnementale deviennent des
problématiques des antilles public le
poisson sont un autre super bon exemple
moi j'étais j'ai appris à l'école vous
mangez du poisson pour être en santé oms
recommande deux portions de poisson par
semaine la garantie pour les migrants
qui oui il ya des preuves scientifiques
que oui manger du poisson deux fois par
semaine ça sans avoir des bénéfices
notamment sur la santé du coeur mais il
reste presque plus des poissons hein ce
fake
comment est-ce qu'on peut encore dire
aux gens manger du thon c'est vraiment
pour vous il ya des mégots trop quand il
reste presque plus que 8 être encore
pour 10 ans voit capable d'en manger
bien manger en aura plus taxés comme
neutres comme si on avait une espèce
d'outils de santé de 10 à manger du
poisson c'est bon mais dans dix ans leur
plus parce qu'il y en a pas tout avoir
pêché on peut garder les aliments sous
une seule l'eau plate et si c'est fini
ce temps je dis c'est que j'ai apprécié
la lecture de ton lit c'est qui qui
t'aime moi même temps on m'avait dit à
manger bio est pas meilleure pour la
santé
j'étais pas bio ou manger les ogm sa
peau n'est pas sur la santé n'ont plus
fait que je m'en fais pas trop avec
sophie même que le monde qui sur les ogm
meza a sévi pisser
la lecture est on le sait à qui il ya
vraiment d'autres loupé d'autres
lunettes à penser quand tu penses à ton
aliment que que la santé de cépie
mettant on vante les vertus de l'avocat
partout maintenant et il est on à vos
clients voyageant moody issue vraiment
éthique ton avec coup d'éclat ça c'est
sûr ça complexifie encore plus les
choses puisque des jeux juste dans la
sphère de la santé oms se pose pas de
questions pas se manquer ce qui est bon
qu'est ce qui pour bon puis l'europe le
stage de l'environnement politique et se
met le sait vraiment mais vraiment le
cas de la vue panoramique et holistique
de la nourriture que que les faits
livrée bon choix puisque je pense plus
vraiment chouette est le choix parfait
existe paul je pense qu'on fut vive
demande des ressources
on est des animaux donc on demande des
ressources de produits punk rap
nourriture comme des planques la demande
de soulagement c'est pour illustrer tu
ne sais pas besoin de ressources
c'est comme le mouvement ce moment de
gens qui n'ont pas d'enfant parce qu'ils
me virent demande des ressources
certainement qui en alimentation c'est
un domaine de la consommation qui est
particulier parce que tout n'importe
quel autre domaine de la vie de
consommation tu peux acheter usagers ou
presque
c'est comme ça fait un an que j'achète
juste comme des vêtements usagés puis
comme je trouvais très content avec ça
parce que c'est bien beau mais ce serait
limite comme c'est tellement l'ex avec
hbo ok mais non mais ça me fait vraiment
que ça me go c'est trop de voir comment
quand on produit les vêtements subtilisé
pensais pas avoir fait que je peux
acheter usagers l'alimentation tu ne
peux pas acheter usagers soient toujours
acheter des nouveaux aliments de
toujours les produits pour capable de
vivre parce qu'on ne peut produire nous
mêmes notre propre nourriture
intrinsèquement donc c'est à dire c'est
que l'impact zéro n'existe pas il va
jamais existé si comme il faut aller
comme plus loin qu'il faut
faut pas se mettre en fait faut pas se
mettre des limites qui disait comment je
vais arriver à zéro peut avoir non c'est
possible l'autre jour avoir besoin de
demander des ressources mais est ce que
tu es vivant il ya des méthodes durables
de création de ces ressources le oui
c'est pas grave elle si j'avais lu un
article qui disait parce que mettons en
ce moment ce serait impossible de
nourrir la planète bio le
parce que ça prendrait trop d'espacés
par contre j'avais lu l'article disait
que si demain matin tout le monde
arrêtez de consommer de la viande qu'on
on coupait toute la production de
végétaux décidé à nourrir le bétail
on pourrait nourrir la planète bio t il
nourrir la planète bio j'ai l'impression
que c'est vraiment plus durable que ce
qu'on fait en ce moment en fait piot
le problème est le problème bio la base
par cette philosophie
on essaie de faire les choses avec un
impact moins grand sur l'environnement
mais c'est devenu une industrie c'est
devenu réglementé puis comme ça du bon
comme ça du mauvais la réglementation
donc ça nous assure que si on dit que
c'est bio ça a été fait de telle façon
voici comment ça a été fait comme moi on
est capable d'avoir une glycine pour les
consommateurs des cas on achète bio on
sait que le manque certain qu'elle s'est
vraiment bien oui exactement c'est
certifié se réglementer puisse y mettons
cet écrit bio sur un aliment que c'est
pas vrai et des organismes qui y sont là
pour vérifier que c est vraiment
respectées y ait des amendes qui sont
donnés tout non quand même on peut s'y
fier mais ce que ça fait c'est qu'il ya
des gens qui vont sont pas bio mais qui
font des agriculteurs mais qui font les
choses bien et mieux encore que le bio
donc le bio c'est moi la finalité on
pourrait aller encore plus loin que des
méthodes de production qui ne sont pas
considérés comme étant by you make me
sont bonnes vraiment bonne équipe et on
va en continuant à développer de plus en
plus
est-ce que des exemples dessus mais
c'est pas nécessairement que 10 des
appellations en tant que tel mais c'est
juste vraiment des méthodes de culture
particulière le faudrait plus parler à
ses agriculteurs l'ont particulier mais
que met-on ils vont utiliser ces
méthodes là en particulier ou est-ce que
à qui je donne un exemple la
permaculture maintenant permaculture
sais que tu vas pas labourer les champs
tu disposes d'intrants comme g j'ai fait
un projet de semences ancestral qu'est
avec une semence assez comme tout dire
de l'hérault spécifique wade cette
égalité de fruits de légumes qui ont
presque disparu qui parce qu'ils
répondaient plus aux critères
d'aujourd'hui textes ou des variétés
très particulière qui elle sa vie sa
mission dans la vie c'est de faire vivre
ces variétés de fruits de légumes up qui
disparaissent pas maintenant pas si vous
connaissez l'histoire du melon de moria
t on avait entendu parler on entendait
hockey à montréal
il ya plus que sentant cultiver un melon
cet élément de montréal montréal c'était
des terres très fertiles s'était pas
industralisés à venir ferme puis sur
l'île sur l'îlot en cultiver peas
étaient reçus par fertile sur les mails
maintenant si c'est du béton qui parle
puis on a retrouvé ce melon montréal on
a retrouvé des menus à new york que
comme diminue que plus que cent ans est
ce qu'on vendait une tranche du montreal
merlen le même prix qu'une tranche 2 de
steak métro et ça veut dire quel point
que ça ça valait super cher s'est
construit comme quelque chose de
vraiment très succinct mais au début du
20e siècle comme montréal à continuer à
s' industralisés bien les fermes ont
commencé à vendre leur père à la ville
puis donc le melon aux disparus qui donc
les dernières fermes qui cultivent et
ont vendu au début du 20e siècle ils ont
vendu leurs terres donc le melon disparu
jusque en 1990 et un journaliste de la
gazette qui tombe sur l'histoire du
mémorial qui comme voir qu'on cultive et
à montréal selon la langue commence à
faire des recherches python sur une
variété de seraing pas moins une banque
de semences aux états unis où est-ce
qu'ils avaient un sachet de melon parce
que c'est cuit montreuil méline sur la
cession de ballons mais qui commande le
sachet piper partenariat avec un
agriculteur d'ici pour planter ses
semences la d200 semences qui avait dans
le sachet une seule crise a poussé puis
à produire le melon qui on a réussi à
faire revivre cette variable
qu'est-ce que disparu de melon ok je
sais une histoire de fric de fruits il
en existe des centaines et des centaines
de fruits de légumes qui ont disparu
totalement qu'on retrouvera probablement
jamais la mâture majorité ont disparu
comme ça m'est donc c'est seulement
sarlat elle son bus et deux pincées mary
seela cultive en permaculture
elle est donc elle ne laboure pas aimer
pas d'engrais mais pas de pesticides ou
quoi que ce soit si on est tombés sur
l'île bizard si un chevreuil qui arrive
dans son chantier qui bouffent la moitié
des haricots baissé comme robin au
niveau des haricots
pis ses savates sopi c'est correct
l'enfant elle son but est d'écrire plus
des environnements mettons à la fête des
étangs pour attirer attirer les
grenouilles d'attirer les couleurs qui
vont comme aidé à tuer des insectes
quiétude comprend un peu le vernis elle
est mise plus sur l'hymne les phénomènes
naturels et écologiques plutôt que sur
les intrants
de d'engrais ou de pesticides pro
capable de cultiver avec m c'est une
méthode c'est pas bio aurait pas
certifiées biologiques mais alors quand
même souci environnemental de cultiver
de cette façon là bon elle qu'on est
capable de nourrir toute la planète de
cette façon là je sais pas c'est parce
que tu dis mais sauf que là comme notre
façon de cultiver c'est la méthode
conventionnelle qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui long qu'avec les ogm les
engrais et les pesticides et poussins du
beau coup d'arrêt des labos coûts de
recherche et développement qui a été
fait dans ses pensées ses façons de
procéder là donc on a réussi à être
super bon pied à produire des petites
surfaces à produire beaucoup mais si on
faisait de la recherche et du
développement sur ses autres méthodes
qu'on mettait de l'argent pour faire
cette recherche ont utilisé la science
près capable de de le faire mais on
serait peut-être capable de produire
autant avec ses autres variétés d'autres
méthodes
si on avait les sommes et l argent pour
faire la recherche
parce que là on a eu des décennies de
d'argent investi pour faire la recherche
pour maximiser la production et pourquoi
s'en faisait la même chose en ce moment
même avec des méthodes qui sont plus
durables
mais on serait peut-être capable de
produire davantage fait pour moi c'est
comme je trouve qui comme trop tôt pour
dire on peut nourrir la planète avec le
bio maintenant sauf si on en arrête de
manger de la viande parce que mr on
pourrait développer de nouvelles
méthodes qui seraient plus durable que
qu'est-ce qu'on a présentement mais
clairement qu'en ce moment sont veut
nourrir tout le monde oui
consommer moins de viande je pense que
c'est inévitable je pense que c'est
comme cela qu'on demande de plus de
ressources mais ton ton lit justement
sauver la planète mouche à la fois je
sais pas si tu es consciemment contre
ton livre de même mais j'ai l'impression
que dans les premiers chapitres et les
choses les plus faciles mais tant qu'on
peut faire pour changer ces
comportements puis avant la fin de ces
mettons pas son propre potager sur son
balcon ce sont des choses qui demande
d'investissement des gens plus advanced
un peu que cette embauche pas eu lieu
mais peut-être qu'un jour je vois pas
mais les premiers justement juste sa
voix à l'épicerie quoi acheter qu'est ce
que ne faisait pas que simon et pâques
quels poissons
de pêche durable se tait manger local
the pipe
parce que je pense mais bon c'est une ag
par les choses qui sont les plus les
choses qui elycia sont celles qui sont
pragmatiques font un gros impact et
apprécié est à part établi par l'epa les
choses les plus les plus avancées et les
plus injustes les manières de pau gaspis
nourriture ce qui m'a surpris c'est moi
j'avais l'impression qu'il est plus
grand que l'endroit où on gaspille plus
sa nourriture ses lesparre marché qui
j'ai énormément de nourriture soit que
dans son livre c'est excellent pour
sabla les gaspillages se fait à la
maison à la consommation très bon c'est
vraiment là que le gaspillage est le
plus intense et les gens qui lie ce fait
partie de ces gens qui pourraient les
choses dans leur frigo et puis tout le
monde est coupable de ce qu'est vraiment
le qu'on peut vraiment changer quelque
chose de gros lot est absolument pis si
c'est drôle parce que en réalité je peux
penser comme moi je met les trucs les
plus faciles début pu être plus
difficile à la fin ou non peu importe le
sujet déjà donné 100 trucs qu'on peut
faire à la maison qui quelque chose que
toi de trop facile peut-être que moi je
trouve ça difficile et vice versa à
chacun veut y trouver son compte qui
justement
oui et des trucs que tu veux je fais ça
depuis cinq ans moi j'ai déjà passé
oui bravo qui tant mieux c'est pour ça
que je l'aimé trucider truc très simple
en disant tu mets ton jeu même recyclé
on va dire si j'ose espérer que beaucoup
de gens et je sais que la majorité des
gens risquent même si je sais que ce
n'est pas le cas mais mais ce best
garrabé le risque se fait déjà sur des
coûts informatiques écoulé déjà embarqué
dans le mouvement écolo parce que
jessica qui je peux faire de plus avec
mon but c'était vraiment une chose
supercinq que tu veux dire je fais déjà
work ychoux banquier je peux passer une
mixtape dit aussi des trucs plus
complexe pour que ceux qui se font déjà
beaucoup à la fin nathan élevé c'est
propre frère luigi pas tout le monde
saura à ce niveau mais se voit quand je
lis écrit c'était encore plus que
maintenant moi je décris en 2014 et 60
en 2015 qui menancent comme on s'en va
voir le moi je garantis que d'ici une
couple d'années le ikea va sortir son
propre
éleveur d'insectes pour la maison c'est
un meuble sûr à 100% ça va vraiment
devenir plus grands succès un aliment
justement qui vaut
qui vaut contrer certains problèmes et
ont comme la famine si on utilise
vraiment bien et ces éléments là parce
que environnement tard possible fait à
produire je pense que c'est quand même
un espèce de produits miracles et
métiers question je vous dise ils m'ont
mis rock à aucun miracle d'avis mais qui
pourrait vraiment être non on parle
l'entomophagie c'est comme on en parle
beaucoup comme justement une des six
solutions là je pense pas que c'est
comme la solution le repas tout se mette
en marche des insectes mais maintenant
je pense pas qu'elle est la solution
je pense qu'on l'a déjà la solution
demande juste de manger moins de viande
des gens règlerait la majorité des
problèmes mais admettons là ou là où
c'est intéressant les insectes et que
oui ce produit donc des protéines donc
ce qui comme si tu regardes un point de
vue très macro le tri à la planète en
entier les êtres humains doit avoir un
certain nombre de protéines donc quand
on regarde le chemin des pays qui sont
plus son développement donc le ca peut
être plus problématique non bref oui
c'est intéressant dans une source de
protéines pour nourrir l'humanité qui
peut être produite à faible coût
environnemental
donc c'est super intéressant mais le
problème c'est que quand une fois
l'alimentation c'est pas juste cérébrale
au juste comme ça je vois des chiffres
dont je suis convaincu utica et juste 3
kg co2 produit par nous on s'en fout le
dit le côté plaisir d'écouter les tous
ceux et cultures qui sont adam piller là
le gros problème c'est qu'au québec
manger des insectes ça fait pas parce
notre cuisine entoure ce dégueulasse de
manger des insectes donc clairement il
va falloir que la barrière soit passé
avant qu'on soit rendue en consommer
mais c'est commencé comme encore une
fois quand j'ai écrit mon livre le
premier league
c'était vraiment plus lourd depuis
maintenant quelques années seulement on
commence à retrouver plein de produits
au supermarché qui contiennent des
insectes j'essayais déjà des craquelins
des grillons mais c'était de la poudre
de grillon ses succès passés sous le
symbole exactement puis d'enfoncer une
grotte leur un insecte et direct
exactement puis ces aliments le sont
faits pour être comme l'espèce de
transition comme on n'est pas capable
encore de 2008 ce site il le prendre
l'insecte le croquis antilles c'est trop
loin de nos habitudes autres sont contre
ou des groupes tout mais quand tu te
transformes sous forme de poudre utile
mais dans des craquelins dans une pâte
dans dix bars pour sportifs il aime
beaucoup les débats pour sportifs comme
ça ouais
tu les vois pas tu lis goûte pas sur
ceux qui sont dedans mais comme cela ça
dérange pas les consommer fait qui comme
pour moi on est en ce moment dans
l'offre de transition et que l'on est en
train de vie suspects de transition l'a
peut-être que dans dix ans quinze ans
comme société on est rendu que auspices
pire finalement pouvoir trouver comme
des chips comme delhaize barbie cupid et
cliqué salle yves daigle ça se pourrait
le comme moi je serais pas surpris qu'on
les voit plus fort mentalement tout
d'animer en ce moment dans la période de
transition à mon sens moi j'avoue que
dans son livre quand j'ai lu quotidien
mais mettez en avant votre qui est une
bonne caisse au vert
si l'idée de titres iliad est attaqué
c'est pas la foire qui la plus
esthétique ténébrions je tenais à
l'époque quand j'écris ça parce que
clairement qu'aujourd'hui si j'aurais
gère écrivait ce serait vraiment plus
forme de poudre que je pourrais payer
parce que c'est vraiment ce qui pour moi
est comme la façon de les consommer qui
vous rendent ce plu plus normal la
blonde alors je sais pas pourquoi à la
une fixation plein genre de blocage mais
c'est une phobie l' on avait jamais
parlé de ça notre vie qui de manger des
insectes
un matin on se réveille on se lève la
première chose qu'a dit a dit ensuite
obligé de manger des insectes
elle a attendu sur mes jeux olympiques
pas malgré l'exemple comme l'humanité va
manger des insectes piqueurs
à propos d'un possible arrêt se veulent
déjà pleins d'autres solutions pour
diminuer notre impact pour nourrir
l'humanité sans avoir à stony face à
tout cela mais juste pour terminer si
j'ai des insectes comme l'autre intérêt
aussi que je vois c'est pour nourrir des
animaux en personne sim et on vous les
doigts
on voulait diminuer les packs de la
production animale mais on pourrait
nourrir les avec des moules et donc
démoulez qu'on préfère ma partir d'un
siècle par exemple lieu deux étaient à
peu près chalet dans un centre de
recherche on aquaculture au nouveau
brunswick peu ils font du projet c'était
comme toutes les guerres qui ont leur
doctorat
c'est comme se rendre au parce que le dr
assez voir comment est-ce qu'on peut
élever comme l'ombre le chevalier donc
c'est une espèce de poisson apparenté au
saumon mais de façon plus durable quand
on sait que yahvé comme foule de bassins
et plaisir et des mous les différentes
études dont notamment qui vont contenir
des insectes mais pour avoir l'impact le
moins grand possible peut être capable
de produire ces aliments que les gens
veulent consommer l'enfant avec l'oci
est quand même une avenue qui on sait
capable au moins de diminuer l'impact de
la production animale
même si encore une fois je pense que
c'est inévitable qu'on doit diminuer la
consommation animale l'importation veut
diminuer l'impact sur la place sur la
planète people pourrait revenir au guide
ouais nan mais parce que je veux qu'on y
revienne mais l'ont pas beaucoup depuis
tantôt de l'impact environnemental mais
on a commencé en disant que le nouveau
guide prenait sans considération ben
ouais si le nouveau lui qui va sortir
éventuellement ouais nan fond le nouveau
guide en ce moment c'est pas vraiment
qu'est-ce qui va voir dedans
donc oui il ya eu des fuites l'axé qui
sont sortis mais cédé version brouillon
puis santé canada comme réagi en disant
ce cd version brouillon il ya des
messages la dent qui ne seront qu on
sait même pas exactement affectés c'est
sûr que c'est difficile de se prononcer
là dessus par contre en 2017
santé canada avait déjà publié des
lignes directrices de sur coise et reste
basé fait que c'est quoi jean les
messages que nous on veut utiliser pour
avoir nos recommandations
dans ses recommandations le y avait we r
et l'environnement ma famille dit
décontenancé par fond de deux façons une
i10 et de privilégier les protéines de
sources végétales
donc ça c'est une façon de prendre en
compte puis si je me trompais une autre
recommandation si ou est-ce qu'on
parlait plus de 10 il faut penser
environnement juste juste de dire le mot
des jeux ça montre sa volonté politique
de il faut qu'on tienne compte de ce
canton recommande à la population de
caisse qu'elle doit manger non peut pas
juste penser aux nutriments faut penser
de façon plus large donc vie je
m'attends quand même à ce qu'on soit
capable d'arriver un petit peu épicée
trop par pitts polt gros changement se
fait pas du jour au lendemain mais we
are petit peu je pense que oui ça
pourrait sembler moins dans dans
l'article de la presse qui parlait de
suspens steve le trois jours jeudi et
ses sorties il y avait une phrase qui
est je l'écris la france la volonté de
ne pas prendre d'études subventionné par
que le bio qu'un le livre il se tait
l'exemple même utilisait c'est
évidemment les produits laitiers pas ce
que c'est ces premières ceux qui écopent
le plus dans la version préliminaire
qu'on a vu le thé c'est le produit le
type la recommandation de fond les
possibilités sont plus un groupe et le
moteur apparente de ce qu'on aurait pu
cette catégorie l'appui ferait partie
des aliments protéinés ou même titre que
mettons les légumineuses que la viande
quel poisson que le tofu ou peu importe
on les mettrait tout dans cette
catégorie le comme les aliments
protéinés comme ça serait ce la nouvelle
classification certain que l'industrie
s'en alarment la plus parce que c'est
les écoles les hôpitaux basent leurs
menus en plus solide et le mental c'est
comme du jour au lendemain la demande
diminue de beaucoup la csq main mais
d'enfants parce que l'autre cosquer
pauvres beaucoup été dit dans les médias
c'est que souvent ce qu'on disait c'est
comme mon dieu puis deux groupes l'on
recommande plus des ports sont consommés
de l'été ou de boissons de produits
laitiers mais la réalité c'est qu'on ne
recommanderais plus de ports sont point
final
même pour les légumes melons
recommanderait plus de portions ou des
donc déjà ceci comme tu peux juste le
lait le cégom il y aurait plus le
concept de portions puis de manger un
minimum de soutien minimum de sens avec
déjà là c'est pas juste les quilles qui
touché par sa monde ne recommande qu'une
portion mais oui bien sûr que
l'industrie des terres empresas cette
chose là parce que c'est comme un acquis
qu'ils avaient le dire nous là on a un
groupe les aliments qu'on produit d'un
groupe spécial dans le guide
qu est ce qu on dit faut que tu en
manges à table je vais t'en santé
c'est-à-dire guide c'est comme tu dois
manger cette catégorie dénommée si tu
vas être en santé
donc c'est clair que oui d'un point de
vue et de l'industrie c'est l'fun
d'avoir ce 10e jeu prouve quelque chose
que le gouvernement dit qu'on doit
manger donc les
écoles les hôpitaux les centres de
personnes âgées est gérable tous les
menus qui font ça va en tenir compte et
sont donc c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent c'est sûr
qu'ils vont sonner l'alarmé sûr qu'ils
vont pas être contents d'avoir ça parce
que besala rouler cette espèce de de
piédestal sur lequel il avait été mis
pendant de nombreuses années puis donc
santé canada cette fois-ci effectivement
ne s'est pas prête à fermer la porte aux
lobbys de l'industrie
c'est sûr que l'industrie avait quand
même encore son mot à dire comme nous on
avait notre moisés eu des périodes de
consultation parce que même où on
pouvait envoyer des lettres outils comme
écrit mme donner notre avis tout ça donc
l'industrie aussi bien sur leurs jambes
mais hésité comme au même titre son voeu
que nous cette époque genre venez vous
asseoir
on voit comme jazy puis on va voir
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce qui
était plus comme ceux dans les dernières
années en fait il y avait des versions
2007 par exemple il y avait un comité
qui avait été mis en place dont des
experts en nutrition qui était mis en
place pour 10 rebonds mais vous qu'est
ce que vous pensez qu'on devrait
maintenant dans le guide qui parmi cette
table là il y avait des gens qui
travaillent et où qui avait travaillé
pour des industries comme les
producteurs laitiers ou comme intérêts
avec ceux ça qui a eu un conflit
d'intérêt ou pas ou comme qui a eu une
influence à cause de ça on pourra jamais
savoir vraiment mais l'image que ça
projettent leur santé canada et posée
qui tenait en compte les impacts
économiques qu'elle à voir maintenant
les guides oui sauf qu'en même temps ça
c'est normal qu'un gay de face t
l'histoire du guide
l'histoire non mais les guide
alimentaire le ca a été développé en
période de guerre
hungry donc où on avait un contexte qui
était très différent
tavin contexte parce que ont manqué on
avait du rationnement parce que c'était
la guerre puis les problématiques de
santé publique c'était les carences
nutritionnelles intelligent avait pas
suffisamment nutriments pour être en
santé que j'allais scorbut il est malade
comme ce genre exactement
sauf que allez donc à l'époque ça
faisait du sens de dire non mais si vous
voulez être en santé voici les aliments
que je devais manger comme ça c'est
comme notre façon de dire s'ils mangent
un minimum de 6 pi 2 sopi de ce chaque
jour il va voir tous les nutriments dont
ils ont besoin pour voir régler les
problématiques de santé publique pis
mais du lait mais ton on en produit au
canada pied on est en période de garde
tout c'est normal qu'on va dire révélé
qu'on produit parce que ces locaux
contredit c'est normal c'est vraiment
normal qui s'étonnera de l'abus quoi que
ce soit c'est normal que le kid pense à
l'économie ça fait aussi partie des
demandes du gouvernement
mais avec le temps la philosophie du
guide est restée la même pendant très
longtemps de continuer à dire manger un
minimum de sites qui mange un minimum de
temps de deux portions de soupçons donc
c'est la même philosophie qu'avant mais
notre contexte avait changé aujourd'hui
on mange beaucoup plus globalisé ce à
dire que manger les produits de notre
pays seulement sait plus vraiment comme
ça commence juste d pad aérienne jambon
exacompta vraiment mais c'est vrai nom
mais dans les premières versions
l'arrivée des affaires comme si de
l'huile de foie de morue pid manger
manger du foie ou des choses comme ça
m'est passé des éléments qui étaient
disponibles dans les autres pays
pis qui était riche en nutriments pilule
est un produit qui riche en nutriments
pis mais bon là on l'a on arrache et de
la vitamine d dans l'est parce que le
lait c'est un élément qui était
consommée par tout le monde qui ont
manqué de vitamine d mais qu on a dit
bon hormis 9 tandis que ça va régler ça
à régler des problèmes donc faut pas
croire que c'est comme ouvrir maléfique
mans comme donné dit nettement non sert
à régler le problème c'était vraiment
une bonne idée de faire contexte a
changé le monde contexte a changé
aujourd'hui nos problématiques de santé
publique c'est l'obésité les maladies
cardiovasculaires le diabète le cancer
on mange trop on mange trop de
transformer donc de continuer à dire
manger un minimum de 6 pi mange un
minimum de ce ça marche pas ainsi le
premier point de manche qu'on mange pas
assez
le problème c'est qu'on mange trop
comment je trouve transformée comment je
peux les bonnes choses donc ou que la
fille de ce fichage puis c'est ce qui
était à grosse critique de la dernière
version
c'est pour ce qu' aujourd'hui ben on
change mais se concertant le que la
philosophie échangés quel est le concept
de portions et disparu parce qu'on vous
n'aurez plus à dire manger au minimum de
six mines mange un minimum de ce pur
plus penser en termes de vous mangez
moins transformés possible faut cuisiner
la majorité nos aliments faut boire
majorité de l'eau des trucs comme ça qui
sont les conseils qui fit avec notre
contexte alimentaires tels que dans 100
ans si on est encore là où celle du
cinéma dit encore loeb est envasé
michael n'importe quoi ces
recommandations là ça fait depuis
mais ça se peut que dans un contexte de
danse en temps ça fait très plaisir
mais j'avoue par exemple que les
concepts de produits transformés
si je le suis le mettons que c'est
couper les prix de transformer mais
c'est quand même un peu floue pour moi
c'est quoi un produit transformé puis à
partir de houssen en devient-il mettons
je me doute que les pizza delissio le
congelé à l'épicerie je me doute que cet
impôt de transformer mes temps mais
c'est quoi un produit transformé en fait
les mains tenant la baraque et moi je me
fie sur une classification qui s'appelle
la classification nova inquiet c'est un
concept qui étaient inventées par des
chercheurs en nutrition
un petit peu partout dans le monde mais
c'est une équipe au brésil en tant que
tel pierre un chercheur notamment qui
tirait qui d'un travail linux montréal
au département nutrition
bref nova c'est une façon de classifier
les aliments justement selon leur type
de transformation qui donc leur but est
justement de rendre plus claires pour
les consommateurs que des mots mais on
veut se baser là dessus pour donner des
recommandations donc le guide
alimentaire brésilien qui était déjà
acquis le des randonneurs version qui
est sorti une couple d'années ils se
sont basés là dessus c'était comme le
premier guide télé quand j'ai vu comment
l image de nîmes étaient contrôlés comme
console de jeux vidéo
c'est comme ceux ci comme la 4ème
génération mais pour moi le guide besoin
c'est comme le premier de la nouvelle
génération des guides et les boks du
genre c'est comme c'est le nouveau delà
de la nouvelle jeunesse le premier d'une
nouvelle génération de l'apli étendre
l'influencé de liquides un peu partout
dans le monde c'est le meilleur pour moi
c'est parce qu'il sait comme il arrive
ailleurs lui comme ils ont compris comme
notre contexte changent et on mange trop
manchots transformer donc on doit penser
à transformation comment quand il
fonctionne grâce aux tic à ces aliments
quatre catégories
tous les aliments frais et peu
transformés ceux-ci des fruits et
légumes légumineuses décret anti la
viande le poisson ou sommet que grosso
modo taux peuvent être grand chose
d'autre que les acheteurs et le kid de
fusil découpez les congeler des trucs
comme ça c'est des petites modifications
qui change pas grand chose sur la sur
l'aliment en tant que tel écrin ces
réalités de cui mettons nous dans le bon
ceci
ce la majorité notre alimentation
devrait être leur seul le premier niveau
loin après ça tous les ingrédients que
dinard excès des ingrédients que qui
mangent pas dans la vie généralement
tout seul un peu la farine ceux là même
la farine doit participer c'est mettons
les au sucre non merci avec le sucre les
huiles par exemple le sel plus avec sont
les utilisent pour cuisiner des recettes
de manière générale donc on va prendre
justement comment on va faire on les
suit ce que justo cuisinons je pénètre
les curistes d'un seul les épices ne
sont pas là bas c'est vraiment les
épices il fait partie des aliments frais
peut transférer parce qu'un ep sont au
niveau des épices et des parcs plantes
que de sécher souvent fait donc ça fait
partie de la catégorie frais et peu
transformés
don king n'a qu'une hâte c'est une
petite transformation des phares du
sucre mais t'en fous tu pars de la canne
à sucre que tu vas tu es maintenant
faire de l'huile bates va prendre on dit
d'un ton dès lundi des noyaux d'olive et
des olives mais ton petit veau faire de
l'huile de toile est pressé de se faire
de l'huile d'olive avec tant que des
modifications qui sont faites des trucs
comme étant la levure et le mental
apparemment ça ferait pas partie de l'ue
sont donc tous les ingrédients qu'il
n'appuie c'est la recommandation par
rapport à ça c'est utiliser les
ingrédients culinaire pour cuisiner avec
des aliments plus transformés en petites
quantités witt et utilisent mais pas
trop apprécié tous les aliments
transformés aliments transformés ceci
quand ce mix les deux premières
catégories fake des aliments frais peut
transformer pie les ingrédients qu'il
n'a fixé par exemple c'est du pain mais
ton examen de la farine de l'outlet se
repaît de base
est-ce que tu changes de la levure du
sel de l'eau qui dépend d'eux
la farine que je pu les inquiéter
justine et prépare une recette de base
de pain aliment transformé
sinon quand tu fais des concerts mettons
donc que tu vas acheter du neuf du sel
pour faire tes concerts où tu achètes et
conserve au magasin bon peu importe donc
des aliments transformés du fromage par
exemple ou peut-être quand même des
transformations camp nou et fait
produire mais les méthodes les
maîtresses ou le laisse un aliment peut
transformer parfois parce que c' est il
directement qu'il a récolté de la vache
tu as titre donc c'est plus vraiment en
forme et donc les aliments transformés
ceux ci consomme usant de temps en temps
mais pas trop grosso modo c'est donc un
petit chiffre encore une fois cette
année mais on en mange mais de façon
limitée dans la catégorie si les
aliments ultra transformer le mâle
transformer ce cd ainsi des aliments qui
contiennent généralement peu ou pas
d'aliments frais de d'ingrédients frais
beaucoup d'ingrédients que d'une heure
mais surtout qu'ils vont contenait
beaucoup d'additifs classes et les
boissons gazeuses les repas congelés
tout préparer les bars temps les
céréales à déjeuner il ya crème glacée
les croustilles les craquelins lui
whatever toutes ces aliments leur qui
aujourd'hui en passant constitue une
galerie sur deux qu'on mange au québec
le don c'est devenu une super grosse
partie de notre alimentation
ce sont eux les aliments qu'on devrait
éviter au maximum la recommandation
c'est consommer post allemand si ça
revient place qu'on ne parle aux débuté
dès fois que voile dans l'extrême sont
veut donc par contre en compte dans les
études que dès que tu manges de
cisaillement là ça semble avoir un
impact néfaste sur la santé qu'ils ont
de plus en plus d'études qui montrent
que donc ils pillent ont regardé sommes
en plein pépin un pays différent que
plus parle ce pays on mange de ces
aliments leur plus haut taux d'obésité
de maladies cardiovasculaires de diabète
ou se dit par le passé on a souvent eu
la l'espèce de tendance de dire à ckoi
qui est mauvais dans ses aliments lost
eu les additifs tulle sel c'est une
grosse du sucre plomb pour et edwards a
su qu'il m'avait non ces groupes
souhaitons pointé du doigt chacun la
réalité c'est qu'on sait pas vraiment
lequel s'est probablement toutes ses
facettes l'homme est aussi plein
d'autres qu'on connaît pas encore
peut-être la transformation tant qu
elles qui subissent que qui va avoir un
impact
et donc ce que ça veut dire c'est que on
sait pas pourquoi exactement mais il
semble que plus tu manges de six
allemands le moins que tu vas être en
santé donc on évite ces aliments est
grosso modo ce ça répond au contexte
d'aujourd'hui parce qu'aujourd'hui on
mange trop on mange trop de transformer
fake
si tu veux être en santé il faut que
manger le plus frais possible qui
souvent les gens quand même quand j'en
reparle du guide se fige 0 aimer et nous
il un guide qui lie ce qui regarde ton
guide son guide qui se dit ah si comme
je vais comme commence à faire mon
acides comme ça demain matin pour ce le
vrai pouvoir du guide on ne parle tantôt
que c'est comme ça va aiguiller ce qui
va être offerts dans les hôpitaux et les
garderies dans les écoles its mais aussi
c'est que la méthode dans mon guide
on dit faut que tu manges le plus frais
possible puis que tu cuisines à plus
possible à la maison grand canada 6 or
ce qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est que
ok moi tout ce que tu as envie qu'eux
mais sachez que la population de
cuisiner au maximum donc il faut que tu
donnes des outils la population parce
qu'à val de cuisine effet comment est ce
qu'on peut faire ça aux bêtes être qu'on
pourrait réintégrer des cours de cuisine
à l'école dès qu'ils arrivent
demanderait à ce que tu veux que la
population fasse comprendre c'est là le
vrai pouvoir c'est comme on parle de
recommandations plus on se dit ok
comment est ce qu'on fait le maintenant
pour aider la population à se rendre
jusque là à ce moment ce qu'on veut que
ce sera exactement où tu es que ça
permettrait d'instaurer des
réglementations que l on n'a plus droit
de mettre un fast food en moins de deux
kilomètres d'une école primaire mais ton
d'une école secondaire fait que ça c'est
plus difficile pour eux d'aller danser
mag dans ses restaurants l'aune des
affaires comme ça que s'ils te le guide
à la base qui te dit baye faut qu'on
fasse la presse on trouve des solutions
pour y arriver et que c'est là le vrai
plus avec le temps ça devient ça devient
une espèce de culture collective
la société conseille team étant moins au
primat je me souviens d'avoir vu les
groupes alimentaires d'avoir entendu
parler du guide alimentaire afin que les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui vont qui vont
apprendre avec ces nouvelles données
leur baisse à savoir parce que leurs
bagages ça va influencer toute leur vie
ou qui vont avoir un cours de cuisine
sont arrivés à l'école puis dès la
première année là c'est normal la voie
en cour des comptes un cours de maths un
cours de français pts un cours de
commandes des cuisines pour us avec
normal mais c'est seul vrai pouvoir des
guides c'est qu'on peut changer des
politiques on peut changer
l'environnement alimentaire
c'est ce qui peut avoir le plus d'impact
mettons donc je prends le le guide
alimentaire tel qui est telle qu'ils
maintenant
[Musique]
personne ne suis vraiment mais c'est une
recommandation qui existent mais tout le
monde se porteraient vraiment mieux même
s'il n'était pas optimale
le monde se porteraient vraiment mieux
si on le suivait c'est si on le suivait
plus qu'on le suit maintenant on est
maintenant dans les grandes lignes ce
genre ouais et viandes et substituts mes
tongs leur recul le 5ème kiki qui
pensaient substitut ty non les dons via
les suées légumineuses un substitut mais
qui pensaient substitut c'est comme ça
on se salit la viande et cette section
là c'est la viande métier le guide ils
disaient pas viande de viandes et
substituts voit le pouvoir des moufles
pouvoir de commander plastimo voit
comment chaque petite affaire pouvoir
suprême et pâques parce que maintenant
c'est à la nouvelle version on appelle
ça des aliments protéinés condiments
jean majorité des protéines veille de
sources de protéines végétales mais ça
envoie le message qu'ils n'ont pas tué
la viande en premier on pense aux
légumineuses en famille et c'est ça
qu'on avait dit légumineuses des
substituts exactement mais ça aurait
changé mais le contexte est possible
contexte l'alliance sopi qui constitue
leur peau mais tu vois comment dialoguer
dans les prisons comme à chicken pour
une virgule ou pour un placement non
parce que la france a recommandé de
différence
la catégorie des légumes et fruits et
légumes et fruits parce qu'on veut que
j'en mange plus de légumes de fruits le
signer et le camp s'ils pensent le mais
c'est des choix mais c'est comme lise
effectif et si j'avoue légumineuses mais
ça se peut que ce soit dans le futur
c'est ça se peut très bien pu m'en fait
moi je pense qu'on va voir ce qu'on va
mettre beaucoup plus d'en faire sur les
sources de protéines végétales
parce que une changement sociétal parce
qu'il ya tellement de végétariens chez
les jeunes maintenant tu es mentalement
qui hissent identifient comme végétarien
faut pas oublier le sim questions
d'identité aussi l'équipe qui compte
leurs demandes têtu végétarien répondent
oui alors qu'ils étaient des gens qui
mangent moins de viande mais qui ce
concert pop avec une ia un shift
totalement dans les habitudes
alimentaires qui est en train de se
produire en partie à mon sens pour les
problématiques environnementales
quand tu vois ça ces changements de
d'habitude lopy surtout les jeunes
j'imagine que ça transpire
j'ai changé mon français mr au projet
comme en soirée l'avenir parce que tu
dois dire qu'il ya vraiment chez ce qui
ce fait on est optimiste qui est seul il
est jeune les gens général puis les gens
sont beaucoup plus conscientisés
qu'avant vraiment je suis vraiment
vraiment super optimiste rva sur
l'avenir parce que justement il aperçoit
le sait moi je l' ai vécu un mois c'est
des apprenants que je m'implique plus le
puits en un an j'ai vu un switch entier
a qui ont de personnes qui nous écrire
en disant qu' ils ont acheté notre livre
cd grands consommateurs de l'union a
fait naître les ont commencé est deux
trois quatre jours par semaine afin de
nourrir 10 sépare
par centaines sinon milliers de
personnes qui n'auraient christie's qui
ce qui est énorme en un an à l'éthique
il ya un très gros changements qui se
produisent puis ça le truc que moi j'ai
trouvé super intéressant c'est
typiquement coordonnées conférence j'ai
toujours toujours toujours à la fin
quelqu'un qui est mort c'est toujours
une mère avec sa fille comme toujours là
la mer voir p comme c'est ma fille qui
m'a fait connaître comme vous vos trucs
ou à leurs pis et c est là le livre
diplôme devenu végétarien depuis ou
comme là on a commencé à manger du tofu
depuis qu'on ne lui mettez vous pouvez
pas ce je trouve ça vraiment fascinant
parce que on a tendance à croire que la
transmission des connaissances ça se
passe toujours du parent envers l'enfant
mais le jeu voici maintenant en train de
changer leurs habitudes sur ce passing
c'est vraiment vraiment intéressant puis
donc je suis vraiment optimiste du monde
qui nous écrivent en disant que
qui ont décidé de l'offrir à leurs
parents de cuisine et deux fois par
semaine chez eux parce que sinon leurs
parents ne voulaient pas changer les
habitudes de cuisine sauf qu'il y
accepter l'autre sens et est accepté que
l'enfant facilite du coin mais je
mangeais deux fois vg par semaine ben
c'est moi qui va cuisiner et puis c'est
parti
c'est utile le sud tout seul j'ai fait
une fois un genre d de sauter ou légumes
le asiatique le chez mes parents ils
depuis quand je viens ma mère l'a fait
tout le temps si non mais moi c'est la
même chose
moi j'aurais fait le te fies général tao
de ricardo garde parce qu'ils voulaient
pas manquer aussi connaissait personne à
noël puis mes parents c'est comme la
maintenance a fait partie dès lors ces
cliques de recettes c'est le temps parce
que pour eux ça les accros chips et
comme de cette façon là que j'ai réussi
à la faire comme vraiment vraiment moins
j'en dirai même si le bec
oui mais oui tu montes une recette aux
gens puissent à goûte bon si c'est bon
d'en bouche tellement est tellement
important pour pour le québec en général
oui c'est de conforter notre métier
c'est bon tu sais si c'est comme ça
qu'il faut accrocher le monde mais si la
finalité des recommandations nous
recette là c'est la finalité de tout
laisser comme un feu de cuisine sous la
manche est seul c'est nagui
ceci pour moi c'est les chefs ils ont
une place hyper important pour modifier
que je le dis souvent si oui jean
philippe vraiment un impact ils savent
ces grandes vagues meti je dis souvent
comme ricardo qui est probablement eu
plus d'impact positif sur la santé des
québécois rrq toutes les projets de
santé publique qu'on a fait depuis
toujours parce que il ya encourage les
gens cuisinent - keith hall c'est un
assaut mené époque comme impact de santé
publique elle qui a été évitée comme
coûte santé publique juste part seul
peck ces foules avec oui les chefs ont
vraiment leur place
il disait maintenant mais tant mieux
netflix ont avec tout le pouvoir deux
d'entre eux mêmes qu'ils ont on met
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent dans des
émissions de chef
sur la cuisine métier de l'iemed cic des
grosses productions la série chef
'stable'
où est ce qu'ils vont voir séparer du
sud vont avoir un chef dans le monde
s'épie est en fait beaucoup de ces
zombies c'est de la grosse production le
sait c'est un homme ccc réaliser ces
produits c'est beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent la dame puis c'est qu'un
intérêt très je voudrais par les chefs
qui ont été rouverts la cuisine puis ça
c'est cool mais tu vois ça ça mais c'est
aussi ça m'a fait beaucoup réfléchir
parce que c'est souvent on voit les
hommages de plus non plus transformer
bon clairement on prend de plus en plus
de raccourcis des grains vraie réussite
lorsqu'on parle de base se sont en train
de se perdre de plus en plus on essaie
de renverser la vapeur mais ça risque
sont garde les données l'on mange de
plus en plus transformé fake mais le
côté les livres de recettes puis les
émissions de cuisine sont hyper hyper
par peu place devenue et comme des fois
on me dit est ce que la cuisine c'est
devenu une habitude une habitude du
quotidien mais c'est devenu quasiment un
spectacle parce que comme on le fait
pauvre en nous mêmes qu'on va pas faire
ces recettes l'homme et l'ont regardé
parce que mettons chef teboul on
s'entend oui c'est sur la bouffe kiwis
sur l'accusation de cuisine sans germes
et il va faire qu'une seule de leurs six
divertissement pur et sain où es tu es
en fait de télé réalité sur la cuisine
le type qui sort comme henri jeanson
poche pour les deux contrats qui font
des trucs vraiment malade comme des
bêtes s'est rendu de divertissement
parce que j'aime c'est comme si nous on
ne fait plus vraiment ou si des choses
qu'on a comme arrêter de faire fait que
l'on regarde les gens comment est-ce que
magali olympique le matin oui c'est ça
fait que fait que des fois je sais qu'on
est plus mitigé parce que oui j'ai
vraiment eu un intérêt mais s4c la
logique si on regarde plus cuisiner
c'est juste comme non triathlon juste
pour le fun je sais pas quoi en penser
c'était ça à nos objectifs qu'on a écrit
les intéressait c'était de faire ce
dérèglement on a vécu
puis comme le fait le mans nous avons
des photos par centaines qu'ils ont
cuisiné ceci qu utile ça fait tellement
du ministre
quand quelque chose quelqu'un à cuisiner
c'est à dire qui ont pris la peine de le
faire juste d'apprendre la peine de
faire un repos pitt et d'être fiers
parce qu'ils sont faire si nous l'envoie
d'un titan public qui s'adresse
justement à monsieur madame tout le
monde même des noms vegan il faut
beaucoup ça si c'est pour recruter si tu
faisais un livre la fine pointe de la
cuisine tv pour un l'élite c'est un
groupe sélect ce qu'avec aussi mais
c'est paul x factor effectivement c'est
en fait c'est les deux sincèrement j'ai
l'impression qu'il a besoin d'avoir
justement une diversité de voie pour
atteindre une diversité de personnes
donc si ça fait que oui ça prend des
gens qui vont s'adresser aux gens déjà
convaincu qu'ils vont les pousser à
aller plus loin
puis ces gens-là défricher le terrain
pour que nous on va les suivre par après
mais ça prend aussi des gens qui
s'adressent à la masse pour comme
changer pour changer les habitudes mais
peut-être de façon moins drastique ou à
ce qui est la norme mais qui au final
qu'on va réussir à les atteindre mais
oui ça prend une diversité devoir faire
ça prend des gens qui à lui vont
chercher les convaincus mais ça prend
des jeunes qui ont cherché le nom qu'ont
vécu les mêmes pilotes et que l'autre va
le prendre à ce niveau la toile est
absolument hors jeu personne et ceux qui
justement team parce que j'ai eu
beaucoup de questionnements par rapport
à ça par rapport à l'avion toujours si
je reviens souvent là mais mon discours
est toujours le même pour manger moins
de viande ni pau ne faut pas en manger
pis mais parce que j'ai ce discours là
ça fait que je suis suivi par beaucoup
de gens qui sont vegam qui sont à
l'intérieur
pis souvent les gens venaient me voir ou
qui m'écrivent c'est comme pour quoi aux
gens d'arrêter d'en manger ces camps où
son corps et il était vraiment
intéressante à conférence comme servante
qu'est ce que tu dis mais pourquoi tu
vois pas un stade plus loin pourquoi tu
dois juste
arrêtez s'il vous plaît au peuple comme
tu es si tu es quelqu'un qui est habitué
à manger de la viande qui ont dit si tu
veux faire un changement foot arrête
complètement sur une farce
tant pis tu sois pas m'écouter ne va pas
vouloir mais si je te dis est une
journée par semaine peut pas manger de
la viande une fois bravo bravo peut-être
l'encouragent tels que tu vas est
également passé à deux jours par semaine
exact pour moi j'ai comme toujours gardé
cette philosophie là de dieu regarde de
du reste de ma philosophie en
alimentation sait jamais dans la
réduction de taux rapide et qu'en
gardant le comme on tend vers quelque
chose mais pour moi c'est comme moins
drastiques puis je pense que plus de
gens qui peuvent accrocher à ce message
le petit jean philippe différentes
choses
bah oui mais c'est pour ça c'est pour
ceux que moi mon approche aussi puisque
sa conjointe beaucoup de monde mais
aussi parce que le monde ils veulent pas
se faire dire arrête et tout ce que tu
fais c'est pas bon seppi en une fois par
semaine que tu mange pas de viande mais
six autres jours c'est pas bon jamais
sur ce qu'ils ont fait que celui-ci bon
exactes sont donc répète souvent
justement manger vegan une fois pas par
semaine c'est comme s'il y avait un
million de noms mais c'est oui oui
exactement
ah oui c'est vrai c'est une façon de
voir c'est exactement ça c'est si on est
plein de personnes à faire des petits
changements ça va avoir un grand départ
c'est manger moins de viande comme comme
il n'ya pas de quartier pas manger tard
vient effectivement cette viande te
mange moins
il a précédemment - tu en manges monde
en mange moins manita mangera plus un
peu les chiffres parce qu'on est tous à
des endroits différents dans le bus et
envers le moins possible mais ton ben si
le débutant voire impossible de 6 mai
jeudi mangent moins de six essais tout
faits qu autant dire deux chiffres parce
que mettant les boissons est un peu
importe quoi t'est-ce 3 1 les deux
boissons gazeuses par jour depuis trois
ans - une canette 3 - quand même si
c'est que le moins il faudra du bas et
c'est d'apprendre
oui ça fait que seppi ou parce que je
suis comme prend le moins possible qui
va quand même tendu les courses mon dos
et ça c'est quoi la quantité minimale
mettons pour une boisson gazeuse que tes
gars de prendre mais que tu vas encore
sentir qu'ils étaient peut-être
aujourd'hui c'est une canette
protégeable la quantité minimale très
heureux ça que je trouve moi j'aimais
justement là-dessus mais tu en manges et
un énorme consommateur de viande pitié
j'ai j'ai décidé d'arrêter du jour au
lendemain
pitié ces mots ce type s'était
principalement au début pour
l'environnement mais c'est aussi
rapidement devenue pour l'éthique
animale fait qu il faut faire pour
l'éthique animale c'est pas mal 0 le
chili puis m
j'ai découvert redécouvert les
légumineuses
puis tout le plaisir que j'avais de
manger de la viande
maintenant je les jeux les transférer
ao légumineuses mettant c'est comme les
ja j'ai faites cuire des pois chiches
cibles sont un frigo le géant des
paiements chez c'est parce que j'aime
vraiment sur les recettes que je peux
faire et que j'adore sur mettons un
curry de pois chiches lentilles avancée
du poulet que je m'étais la donne je
préfère les projets du fon refaire ce
vraiment les ti je trouve c'est mieux
puis les légumineuses moi c'est une
découverte le ska monumentale de
tricoter hier le l'espèce de steak haché
c'est fait avec quoi et si c'était là je
capotais le végétal texture enki ouais
mais ça et je m'imagine que son qu'elle
faisceau d'éléments et d'aliments
transformés
ouais sauf que comme remplacer la viande
par semaine je voudrais les steaks
hachés remplacé parce tu t'en rends même
pas compte de tout mettre sens une sauce
à spag donc une belle aux imprimés en
termes de gouges pas nécessairement
mieux mais tout ça pour dire que le
plaisir je les retrouvais ailleurs si
oui que je l'aï enlevée en place mais je
les retrouve ailleurs c'est juste parce
que pour qu'il donne la peine de fortes
c'est toujours une question de culture
on a juste été levée la dame et son
invité lui dans un autre monde mais on
aurait été contents d'en manger dès
notre naissance des légumineuses mais
tant pis attends tu te demandes si
tonton curie de pois chiches le mettons
si comme en inde il ya énormément de
énormément énormément dans qu'ils ont
une cuisine qui s'est développée sur des
décennies voire des siècles pour mettre
en valeur cet aliment la mairie ça
comment faire pour que ça goûte bon
parce qu'au final ce petit but dans la
vie peck pouces faut aller chercher
justement c'est comme si inspiration la
pilule ils ont eu des centaines d'années
pour que ça goûte bon alors légumineuses
comme où on se trouve oui quand vous
trouvez ce bon aussi la wii c'est que
c'est vraiment une question de culture
c'est comme nous nous restons à se
développer autour de la viande mais
comme il ya plein d'autres personnes au
monde qu'ils ont développé autour
d'autres choses ça vaut la peine de les
découvrir à part béton de l'aspect
environnemental pile de regrouper
mettons les aliments à l'emap rétine
également transformé de ce risque et
d'autres nouveautés on le prend corps
dans l'émail mettant dans les fuites le
dans l'audio nouveautés mettons kiki qui
sont majeurs le temps l'autre chose qui
change beaucoup qui s'inspire du guide
alimentaire brésilien c'est de parler
peu juste du contenu de l'assiette mais
aussi de ce qui se retrouve autour donc
au juste de quoi manger
mais le comment manger mais que c'est
des recommandations genre manger en
famille ou bien quand je faisais
cuisiner davantage
donc on dit pas quoi cuisiner andy
cuisine davantage mangent en famille
prend le temps de s'asseoir avec ta
famille tes amis dans un contexte qui
est plaisant mettons donc où vont moins
souvent dans des restaurants de
restauration rapide des trucs comme ça
quand on te donne des trucs comme ça on
ne peut décemment quoi manger là bas est
ce qu'on dit si voici des pas sont de
ramener l'alimentation plus comme une
priorité dans ta vie mais aussi qu'on
nous on sait d'un point de vue
scientifique que oui les gens que ça
soit à table pour manger mais
généralement ils vont avoir cuisiné
peace man l'europe s'il prend le temps
de la voir cuisiner tous que si tu t'es
peut-être décongeler une pizza qui soit
la manger dont on leur dit en écoutant
youtube ou hulu netflix ou peu importe
donc si quand printemps cuisiner ou 30
ans de manger en famille oui donc le
contenu souvent les plus intéressants
même sans qu on ait eu besoin de te le
dire en plus
d'un point de vue social c'est super
important leur poste au moment où
partout sur terre on mange ensemble donc
clairement y ait quelque chose à qui tu
parles que le fait de manger ensemble
des besoins humains
si tout le monde le fait donc c'est bon
pour nous ce n'est pas santé mentale
c'est bon pour créer des liens entre la
famille pour par nos problèmes pour
parler de type n'importe quoi c'est qui
paraît pas important pour le perdu avec
le dans les greffes sait des choses
comme ceux qui qui semble rentrer dans
le guide cave on n'en parlait pas
beaucoup mais classe qui seraient mises
de l'avant dans les versions même qu'on
ne les luminaires et brouillon et wever
sont mises
avant même le haut-rhin nul donc les
premières recommandations c'est le
comment puis après on rentre dans les
excès quand j'ai dit fennell biologique
de la patente si c'est plus loin dans la
hiérarchie de l'importance à 100 bêtise
ça semble être prêt peut au moins
important mais au moins à parts égales
entre le comment pileux quoi manger tous
à 10 ans mais sans avoir compris comment
qui n'ont pas juste qu'on dise les
aliments faut qu'on donne des conseils
qu'on a perdu des choses qui ont été
perdus par notre contexte c'est super
intéressant mais je me rappelle j'avais
commencé à quand j'habitais en
appartement j'avais commencé avant je
mangeais mettons je cuisinais je me fais
de la musique je cuisinais le strip et
après ça je mangeais mais je mange tout
en faisant quelque chose dont je mange
en écoutant un athée les chemins puis
d'amener jeu j'avais arrêté de faire ce
jeu conseil je mangeais du match tout
seul juste manger comme les jeux cuisine
est belle ce que je mangeais ce qui va
cuisiner
l'expérience était vraiment différente
des plus conscients deux premières
manches les plus conscients de leur
résultat de ma cuisine est plus
conscient des des saveurs qui se dégage
été capable de me mettre mais tombe de
réaliser à qui sait ce que je goûte là
pourquoi c'est pas optimale c'est trop
salée août et le gras de balancer mieux
les aliments y aussi une fierté de
francs bonne recette exacte
il y avait aussi après se jeter plus
conscient de mon sentiment de satiété
2 est ce que je suis puni si je t'ai
plein à moitié de mon assiette bien
j'allais porter mon assiette
je m'étais je gardais le reste pour une
autre fois c'était pas poubelle leurs
espoirs
enfin sauf quelqu'un j'ai écouté une
émission je finissais mon assiette
peu importe quoi et combien de dans les
faits comme je mange et je mangeais je
mange et je mangeais le camp du porte
attention à ton sentiment interne
tarascon à qui j'ai pu faire ce
j'imagine que la vitesse avec et
arbitres mange ça mange extrêmement vite
ça m'arrive le souvent déjà vous fait
bouffer bluffant on a évolué pendant des
milliers d'années
ou est-ce que notre corps il nous envoie
des signaux pour nous dire arrête de
manger ou si le temps de manger mais on
ne avec le temps on a arrêté de les
écouter ces signaux l'opt et une
formulation que j'utilise souvent c'est
comme aujourd'hui on est tout le temps
connecté une notification de style de
raymond n'est jamais connecté une
notification de notre corps pourtant il
a plein des messages qui nous envoie
pour me dire c'est qu'ils comment
j'allais de manger mais comme on est
toujours ce n'est celle où qu'on écoute
la télé ou qu'on leur dit en même temps
qu'on mange bref on fait autre chose
manger n'est plus notre activité
principale on fait autre chose parce que
trop plate le jeu cette instance on a
cette chance de quoi d'autre mais on
s'écoute plus qu effectivement de se
manger davantage ce départ c'était si
notre société
mais si oui c'est 'qui faucons mais
quand on mange notre activité si manger
point final tip top 70 à dos et josé moi
même je le fais des fois que je vais
jusqu'à tanger d'écouté netflix en même
temps que je mange c'est sûr aussi comme
ont notamment de stimuli tellement de
façons de faire on s'est habitué aussi
puis on veut on veut être performant on
veut écouter un livre audio ème temps
changent et en même temps de faire autre
chose exactement pis si c'est bon pour
toi aussi tu es un moment de repos
pendant le petit 20 minutes trois fois
par jour là au moins deux types
assure-t-on celles qui passent au
ralenti lips a déjà tout comme un petit
comme des connexions pas aux 120 minutes
à la fois vu juste
c'est comme
dans l'après midi va être naïf parce
qu'après c'est vrai que là pour manger
oui mais oui mais oui tu vois qui sépare
bompas et moi j'ai quelqu'un de très
commun comme dans la vie quelqu'un comme
très performant plus dangereux je
produis je toujours puis j'ai toujours
l'impression que je manque de temps pour
être partagé pas écrire cet article j'ai
passé je parle de quoi
qui donc c'était très facile puis ç'a
toujours été pour moi de coms et là qui
est la priorité c'est le travail puis
c'est tout pile reste de ma vie je on
met de côté parce que je veux travailler
tout le temps puis avec le temps j'ai
comme réalisé que la france j'irais
semble convaincre de prendre le temps de
relaxer pile l'ombre je dépasse même
juste manger le jeu ce temps de relaxer
ou peu importe de faire autre chose
c'était que aux fenêtres les plus
productifs le moment qui tente que tu
t'ennuies poste potes ça peut vraiment
pris un repos comme en vrai repoussé
comme fou tartine le point où est ce que
tu t'es ennuyer le goût de retourner
travailler exactement
bon moi c'est comme la salle du fait
d'une bonne déconnexion pure comment
c'était vraiment mis off plus va être
motivé
mais sinon là on est tellement trop là
dedans qu'on se rend pas compte que la
productivité a diminué parce que tu
prends pas le temps de te reposer pee
wee manger ça devrait être un moment de
repos
mais c'est ce que je l'aimé
questionnaire en lisant son livre je me
disais le goal temps de charger son
potager sur son balcon d'élever sévère
deux fois trente six mille affaires put
écrire des livres d art qui fait non
mais attaquer je le dis dans le livre
que je ne fais pas tous être clos j'ai
testé quand j'ai fait mais maintenant je
n'ai je ne la fait plus d'un siècle que
je les ai faits comme élevé des insectes
quand j'écrivais lit mais comme je le
fais plus mais oui mon potager de balcon
ce gars est là mais faster plaisir pour
moi c'est sûrement manche comme chaque
matin je me dirais que mon café pendant
les types je regarde mon petit fils
comme ça ben oui c'est pour le fun c'est
collé l'addition juste amath cissé genre
est une corvée pis les fous fasse mon
potager c'est la bonne chose à faire
c'est de nous si ça marche
c'est peu importe qu est ce que tu veux
changer comme habitude commence toujours
par les habitudes les plus simples
possibles si je parlais avec militaire
de la fontaine je peux ces blacks là
canéjanais parce que en fait à
travailler à ce niveau puis mon travail
dans ce milieu là qui l enfant c est le
queens zéro déchet oui au québec elle
c'est vraiment énorme mouvement zéro
déchet si elle est vraiment comme qui
j'aime beaucoup son discours est super
bonne en conférence a vraiment au tpi
j'aime son discours parce que dit
toujours on elle tend vers le zéro
déchet le but c'est parce qu'ils sont
quand on part de zéro c'est zéro mais
non c'est comme montant versé d'ici là 6
0 c'est impossible je elle même n'est
pas zéro déchet c'est sa vie mais ce qui
me disait douter quand les gens m'en
parlent aujourd'hui toujours fait la
chose la plus facile que tu peux la
première chose que tu vas faire c'est
pour toi c'est plus avoir de pailles en
plastique est un grand signe et zola
j'achète poupée en plastique c'est
vraiment facile mais oui bravo tu as
déjà fait une étape la prépa sa
prochaine étape commence toujours par
les choses les plus faciles en premier
toutes les positions se sont même pas un
effort à faire
après ça un parent tu peux y aller mais
c'est à dire qu'il faut que je passe à
dix à pissos pisapia pour être bon pé
être capable de ça va jamais marché pour
ce que tu aimais tant ph temps qui passe
et des pratiques d'un carnivore avec
anne d'un coup c'est un peu l'exception
à la règle parce qu'il sait c'est un est
un changement vraiment drastique aurait
été plus progressif si si ma copine
n'était pas
b gagnent déjà premièrement parce que ça
m'a facilité beaucoup la chose parce
qu'elle a fait déjà une démarche que
j'ai pas eu la force et en termes de
retrouver maintenant des des produits le
team et on me serais tombé vegan jour au
lendemain chez nous n'ayant jamais
entendu parler de levure alimentaire
j'aurais été mettons que c'est juste un
exemple jamais entendu parler de thèmes
tuée alors qu'elle a vraiment des pros
si j'avais été seul j'avais j'ai déclic
la sarre était beaucoup plus progressif
- tant que témoin mettons c'est ce qui
est le cas des gens conscientiser les
gens végétarien vegan entre deux toits
ça fait que tout un forum sur le sujet
puis tu comptais qu'ici c'était le
transfert dans la route pitt et moi
mettons ça a été
première étape qui a arrêté d'acheter de
la viande rouge à l'épicerie team joest
encore du poulet bizarrement tout temps
en temps au resto arriver mais je
n'achetais pas l'épicerie première chose
une autre table notre état qu'il a un an
plus tard le ça fait cinq jours j'ai pas
mangé de viande puis j'ai encore envie c
puis j'ai pas l'intention d'en manger
dans les prochains jours puis je
commençais patache végétarien quand ça
fait cinq jours mais c'est quand même un
don pour reprendre ces exemples-là
quelqu'un qui décide qui dit ok moi
toujours la main chaude zéro déchet
change tout tes habitudes en journée
c'est ça devient vraiment s'ils pensent
maintenant le mouvement zéro déchet ça
encore plus difficile que quel mouvement
vegan dans ta vie de tous les jours
c'est tellement encore une fois ce ça
dépend de ou tu veux y aller
ouais c'est toujours top tu te mets tes
propres limite peu importe peu importe
l'habitude que tu chantes avis jour
d'autres mets tes propres limites ça se
peut que pour certaines personnes c'est
plus tough d'être vegan que d'être zéro
déchet aussi donc chaque personne on est
différent on a des habitudes différentes
pis on faut changer selon nous qu'est ce
qu'on trouve le plus facile au départ
ces équipes auront le plus d'impact qui
ont vécu le toffee toute notre ville
puisqu'ils juste pour acheter au point
qui compte près de la table on se tait
d'où l'importance de s'entourer de gens
qui ont cette expérience l'a dit si tu
veux devenir végétarien ou végétalien
qui se découvre de recettes mais qui me
passait que d'autres vegan déjà comme
fait le processus des six communes à
mieux apprendre à pierre
sa cuisine est donc en apprenant
l'expérience des autres c'est comme ça
qu'on réussit à a changé pas construit
de façon plus facile notamment pitt y
ait quelque chose qu'on avait discuté
hier dans le queens et pour nos pays
twins et c'est les mettant les
changements qui fait dans son mode de
vie
puis la conscientisation mais le savoir
et année sur souvent sur les gens autour
de toi t il jamais dieu le peut-être que
les gens autour de toi tes parents tes
amis vont changer leurs habitudes ce
groupe le veau rayonner sur les autres
groupes autochtones et mettons le
exemple la ville de montréal devenu un
endroit ultra vegan faim de liberté où
les gens ont un niveau de concentration
quand même élevé en moyenne mais le la
ville de montréal va rayonner sur les
autres villes de la province sur pilotis
6 comme se tissent apporte des individus
les idées se transmet d'humain à humain
de bouchareb ce comme ceux qui ont
changé concret des révolutions femmes en
ont vraiment vraiment depuis le début
j'ai toujours parié sur le fait que les
consommateurs qui avait le gros bout du
bâton puis c'est là que je voulais aller
parce que oui en politique peut avoir d
une influence kiwi de change et à des
grands niveaux mais au final ça commence
toujours par des demandes des
consommateurs ou des citoyens peu
importe si c'est quand les idées ce
chantier une changement de mentalité le
reste son objectif que soient les
entreprises comme les entreprises sur
leurs premiers comme plus simple on
dirait la présidera la politique qui
soit mais oui ça parle toujours de même
au niveau de la politique
yat il ya deux choses premièrement c'est
les gens qui lisent les gens qui sont le
long petit plus gens sont conscientisés
plus les gens qui sont le reflet de ce
mets même plus que ce pti plus y mettons
exemple de vegan dans population plus
ils vendent et lui est garanti et
mettons parce que si ses demandes comme
voir si c'est vraiment dépité c'est ici
du monde qui ont des enfants puis que
l'ofs le radeau leur fille ado à bien
les gammes qui les y apprennent la
subite est pas qu on est on est tout le
monde
le nombre de fois où j'ai eu des gens
qui m'aiment engagés pour des
contremaîtres ont-ils si genre des
mystères diplômés ton monsieur dans la
cinquantaine ou thé soixantaine peu
importe si j'ai une entreprise qui
m'engage pour mettre en forme de
conférences de fois que ce genre c'est
ma fille qui mord les doigts ou qui
allons cuisine vision concernant le nom
de fax marc rich comme acquis dont les
flancs se fait aussi de loterie des
canaux comme non officiel d' influence
n'a monté cinq france des gens qui sont
armés parce que jean leurs enfants comme
ont décidé de le changer leurs habitudes
et oui vraiment celui-ci c'est le bouche
à oreille ça reste l'outil le plus
efficace pour propager les pattes et
claudine on a parlé de notre invité hier
6 qui accueille business mais qui oppose
je garde les mettez y met pratiquement
rien marketing parce que quand on
produit les banques qui des bonnes idées
se fait son chemin
pour commencer à penser à rapper soi
même et on attend de toi 2019 le même
temps c'est quoi tes à blesser ce couac
s'invite des choses spéciales pour toi
2009 faut que j'écrive mai prochain
livre ouais j'ai déjà commencé
j'ai des idées puis comme vous c'est
quoi toutes façons marché c'est mon jeu
je veux faire c'est comme écrire pour
moi c'est le c'est ce qui me rend le
plus heureux ce fake
bref pour le moment c'est vraiment ça
j'ai planché sur mes prochains projets
de livre qui donne aussi beaucoup
beaucoup de conférences pour le
printemps là j'en ai une trentaine à
travers le québec
ouais tiens lis ça pour l'automne aussi
ça va ex fait la tournée du québec
vraiment conférence fait que les gens
peuvent aller sur mon site qui voit
justement toutes les dates les affiches
sur beaucoup qui sont gratuites le sont
dans les bibliothèques qui est musicale
et ce avec ses yeux dans le fond les les
conférences partout le message en fait
beaucoup pour des professionnels donc
des dissonances des médecins des congrès
et en importe le fait que ce public là
mais aussi pour le grand public donc
dans les festivals dans les universités
et les cégeps les bibliothèques ni
un peu partout on est mal mais ceux-ci
genre en ce moment c'est yvon voire trop
cool et merci beaucoup merci merci tu
pars en dix ans et c'est un sujet qui
touche 100 % la population active tout
le monde est concerné par ce sujet que
ce qu'ils font et je compte à savoir
qu'ils étaient plus de bien que le
pessimisme
[Musique]